on va pouvoir commencer mes chers
collègues l'examen des missions
budgétaires pour lesquelles nous sommes
saisis avec les mission sécurité
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État j'accueille avec vous pour
cela le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres mèes monsieur géralde Darmanin
qui vient de nous rejoindre vous le
savez les auditions menées dans le cadre
budgétaire par la commission des lois ne
se content pas de porter sur les sujets
du bleu budgétaire mais elles sont
toujours l'occasion de faire un point
sur des sujets d'actualité et de
politique générale et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je n'ai pas répondu
favorablement à la demande de certains
d'entre vous d'auditionner le ministre
de l'Intérieur puisque nous avions
l'occasion de le recevoir aujourd'hui en
commission et je ne doute pas qu'il
répondra à toutes vos questions
notamment celles sur les questions de
sécurité donc j'attire juste votre
attention sur deux éléments d'abord que
nous aurons une suspension pour le vote
euh solennel de la loi sécurité
régulation de l'espace numérique ensuite
qu'il y a une deuxième vote qui
m'échappe pour lequel nous euh
suspendrons une motion de rejet pardon
sur le PLF voilà c'est exactement
j'ai pense bête en la personne de
Monsieur le rapporteur et que le
ministre doit nous quitter à 20h donc j'
j'invite à la concision des propos pour
les missions faute de quoi notre
collègue bernalici sera à nouveau privé
de la présence du ministre ce qui le
rendrait évidemment très
chagrin et ensuite nous examinerons les
amendements sur les deux missions après
les discussions générales
vissemblablement après le dîner sauf si
vous êtes tous rapides ce dont
malheureusement je doute monsieur le
ministre bienvenue Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés je
voudrais évidemment vous saluer une
nouvelle fois au moment de présenter les
crédits du ministère de l'Intérieur et
et les outres maires pour
2024 dans un contexte très difficile que
que nous connaissons avec un caractère
bien singulier au moment où je m'exprime
jamais les Français jamais les Européens
n'ont eu autant besoin de de sécurité je
vois d'ailleurs dire que derrière les
données budgétaire les les difficultés
parfois des des argusis et et de la
technique voire de la technocratie nous
avons bien des femmes et des hommes qui
concourent à maintenir la paix publique
dans des conditions si difficiles et qu'
s'agisse des des policiers des gendarmes
des agents de la la DGSI des agents de
de préfecture des personnels de la
sécurité civile de tous ceux qui sont au
ministère de l'Intérieur je vais
évidemment leur dire que le soutien de
des programmes budgétaires n'est rien
par ort au soutien politique je sais que
nous exprimons souvent monsieur le
Président et je remercie d'ailleurs
votre commission et et l'Assemblée
nationale grâce à vous c'estàdire grâce
au parlementaires et et grâce au
parlementa au sens très large du terme
l'année 2023 aura été marquée par
l'adoption de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour la première fois une
loi de programmation pour l'ensemble du
ministère de l'Intérieur et pas
simplement pour la sécurité intérieur
qui consacre donc 15 milliards d'euros
sur les 5 ans à la sécurité des Français
et je le redis devant vous puisqu'il y a
eu des débats politiques parfois
médiatiques pour savoir si cette loi
d'orientation et de programmation serait
respectée elle est non seulement
respectée à l'europrè et la
communication des plafonds a montré que
c'était 200 millions d'euros de plus que
la loi de programmation du ministère de
de l'intérieur et j'exclus le ministère
des autres mèes en vous disant en vous
disant cela non seulement vos crédits
malgré l'inflation malgré les
difficultés budgétaires et difficultés
économiques n'ont pas été renié le vote
des parlementaires a donc étaé tenu mais
il y a même des crédits supplémentaires
j'y reviendrai si vous le souhaitez ces
crédits doivent être exécutés
conformément à la trajectoire que vous
avez voté et si uneinflation est prise
sous plafond de de mesure ainsi que la
revalorisation du point d'indice euh des
des arbitrage interne sont donc
évidemment à conduire en tant que
gestionnaire du du ministère de
l'Intérieur les priorités restent
inchangées notamment grâce au 200
millions d'euros supplémentairire
accordé le renforcement de la présence
des forces de sécurité intérieure
notamment le doublement de la présence
de voix publique qui était un engagement
du Président de la République en 2022
affermir l'administration territoriale
lutter contre le terrorisme ça est bien
sûr d'actualité et bien sûr préparer les
Jeux Olympiques et parolympiqu je
constate que 2023 se déroule
conformément à à mes engagements de
crédit avec l'accueil notamment d'une
coupe du monde de rugby qui jusqu'à
présent se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions de sécurité possible puisque
ce qui m'intéresse évidemment c'est pas
simplement les Bleus qui sont sur le
terrain mais les Bleus qui sont parfois
en dehors du terrain et qui font
respecter la sécurité dans le plus grand
le 5e plus grand événement mondial un
effort sans précédent donc pour
renforcer la présence des forces de
l'ordre et sur la voie publique le
doublement de la présence de voie
publique qui s'est traduit par du
recrutement supplémentaire de personnel
de police et de gendarmerie vous les
connaissez la création qui désormais
sont quasi intégrales puisque 10 EGM et
unités de CRS sur 11 ont été créés avec
des sorties d'écoes par particulière
pour les escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
et pour les compagnies de CRS
1266 policiers qui ont été renforcé dans
les circonscritions de police
prioritaires et notamment cette année et
puis je voudrais évidemment saluer la
création des 239 brigades de gendarmerie
tout augmente monsieur le Président nous
avions prévu 200 sur l'annonce du
président de la République en
conceration avec avec les élus et dans
les premières sorties d'école ont
démontré que mois de juin ils étaient
disponibles pour renforcer la sécurité
dans nos campagnes et dans le monde pis
urbain du matériel également vous
rappelez-vous que les deux premières
années de ma vie au ministère de
l'Intérieur ont permis de avoir d'un
plan de relance notamment qui a pu
équiper les les policiers et les
gendarmes notamment en matériel de
voiture ou d'intervention mais aussi
d'immobilier on y reviendra des
équipements donc renforcés pour les
forces de l'ordre qui continuent 4800
véhicules pour la police et pour la
gendarmerie ont été acquis acquis en
2023 ça se rajoute au
13310 véhicules déjà achetés nous aurons
donc changé 70 % du parc automobile du
ministère de de l'intérieur nous
acquérons en 2024 3600 nouveaux
véhicules pour 130 millions d'euros dont
58 véhicules sans Tor qui intéressera
particulièrement nos amis gendarmes et
nous avons finalisé le plan caméra
piéton puisque'au 1er janvier l'année
prochaine tous les policiers gendarmes
qui sont sur la V publicique et en
contact avec la population seront
équipés d'une caméra piéton dans la
quité des annonces du président de la
République le Gouvernement va déposer un
amendementce concernant le renforcement
des moyens dédiés à la sécurité civile
pour lutter contre les feux de forêt à
hauteur de 140 millions d'euros en
crédit de paiement dont les 45 millions
pour la création de la 4e unité
d'instruction de la sécurité civile les
formises qui s'installera monsieur le
député Boudet que je ne vois pas à
Libourne avec 163 personnel
supplémentair 40 millions également pour
aider les 10 à acheter des véhicules de
Sapur pompier 32 millions pour
renouveler notre flotte de canadaire 23
millions pour louer des moyens aériens
je veux noter que l'année 2023 celle a
été une année qui avait autant de départ
de feu a été une année qui a vu beaucoup
moins de feu grâce à l'organisation et
au travail collectif de la sécurité
civile et du courage de nos saport
pompier parallèlement 2023 VO
l'acquisition des 40 nouveaux
hélicoptères que nous avons évoqué pour
500 millions d'euros et également un
travail de mutualisation entre la
sécurité civile et la gendarmerie
nationale des ressources supplémentaires
it pour mieux répondre à la
cybercriminalité je rappelle que c'est
le début des 1500 cyber patrouilleurs
que vous nous avez demandé de créer et
l'équivalent du 17 cyber des moyens
importants pour la population avec le
succès de Faros dont on voit
l'efficacité aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président de tis mais aussi du portail
ma sécurité et de bientôt de la
généralisation de la vis au plainte que
vous avez vous-même autoriser dans la
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur les moyens dédiés au
servicees de renseignement du du
ministère d' l'intérieur sont sans
équivalent dans leur augmentation il y a
10 ans à la création de la dgsci ont
comptaéit un peu plus de 3200 personnels
aujourd'hui grâce à l'action du
Président de la République nous avons
quasiment doublé le nombre d'effectifs
5500 personnels lorsqu'elle aménagera
dans son futur site unique de
saint-toouin un projet d'ailleurs dans
la lopmie à 1,2 milliards d'euros le
budget de la DGSI aura donc doublé le
son personnel aura donc doublé et donc
je pense que c'est une explication de
son efficacité merci monsieur monsieur
le Président d'avoir rappelé le travail
très courageux des agents de la la DGSI
un effort sans précédent également pour
l'outrem notamment je vais me concentrer
sur l'rem en matière de sécurité puisque
le ministre délégué aux outr mè est
chargé des crédits des Outremers
classiquement visant à répondre aux
enjeu de sécurité de lutte contre les
stupéfiants c'est le cas évidemment
notamment Guyane mais pas simplement des
trafics illicit c'est notamment le cas
aux anti à Martinique en particulier et
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière c'est le cas un peu partout
mais particulièrement à Mayotte o
l'effort a été très important et il doit
continuer à être très important en 2017
jusqu'à aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président 1400 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires ont été affectés dans le
territoire ultramarin c'està-dire une
augmentation de 30 % des effectifs de
police et de gendarmerie singulièrement
à Mayot qui a quasi doublé les effectifs
pour un total de 1150 forces de l'ordre
en dehors bien sûr des escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile et en Guyane pour un
montant également de 1525 forces de
l'ordre en en en en sans compter les
escadrons de gendarmerie mobile si les
opérations dites wouchou ont montré
l'efficacité de la lutte contre
l'insécurité il y a encore du travail à
Mayotte il faut revoir sans doute le
plan chikandra j'ai fait des
propositions à la première ministre au
président de la République et revoir
sans doute les plans harpis avec le
ministre des armées pour ce qui est de
la lutte contre leorpaillage illégal
dans la forêt amazonienne française ces
augmentations des effectifs territoriaux
se doublent par ailleurs de renfor
permanent c'est désormais 21 escadrons
de gendarmerie mobile qui sont répartis
dans l'ensemble des outres mèes et je
veux aussi dire monsieur le Président
que pour la première fois et grâce à la
création à la fois en quatre sections
des unités de CRS mais des nouveaux
escadrons de gendarmerie et de CRS que
vous avez accordé il y avait eu 176
escadrons de gendarm merie mobile ou
d'unité de CRS qui ont été mobilisés
pendant la coupe du monde de rugby qui
nous ont permis de faire face à la fois
la venue du roi et de la reine
d'Angleterre du pape à Marseille dans
une semaine qui est évidemment marqué là
aussi par des menaces terroristes je
pense qu'on le doit aux policiers au
gendarmes qu'on a su mobiliser et aux
effectifs que vous avez su nous donner
après le réarmement de la police et de
sa présence doublement de voix publique
la question du réarmement continu de
l'administration générale et
territoriale de l'État c'està-dire des
préfectures continue même s'il faut
évidemment continuer encore cette
augmentation le renforcement de nos
capacités numériques et cyber je peux
constater que l'acmos fonctionne dans le
réseau radio du futur qui sera une
magnifique que invention française que
nous pourrons exporter qui a commencé
déjà en version beta à être utilisée par
les forces montrant ainsi son efficacité
dématérialisant de bout en bout les
process métiers des étrangers à l'ANF
pour les préfectures avec bien sûr le
projet de loi immigration qui arrive et
qui se permettra une cohérence avec la
réforme des préfectures que je vous
présenterai si votre commission souhaite
m'interroger sur ce point mais également
de France identité numérique puisque
tout le monde peut commencer à avoir son
identité dans le monde numérique que ce
soit sa pièce d'identité que ce soit le
permis de conduire ou que ce soit le
vote dématérialisé avec un process
désormais d'une vote par procuration
sans passer nullement devant un contact
physique en garantissant l'identité de
la personne donc une des projets
évidemment de transformation numérique à
la hauteur de l'impôt à la source que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous
présenter dans mes fonctions antérieures
le poids du numérique a donc été
consolidé au sein du ministère qui
connaissait une dette numérique
extrêmement importante une Haus très
significative de ces crédits en 2024
sont prévu 634 million d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et déjà 576
millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
et nous recrutons les premiers les 75
premiers équivalant temps plein dédié à
l'agence numérique que nous avons donc
créé conformément à la lopmi 35 300
3350 pardon emploi sur la période pour
l'État territorial c'estàdire pour les
préfectures des moyens renforçant la
vidéo de protection 25 million d'euros
en 2024 contre 22 millions en 2023 et
puis la finalisation de la création de
nouvelles préfectures qui n'ont pas eu
lieu depuis plus de 40 ans je vous
rappelle ces sous-préfectures qui sont
en outreem ou sur le territoire
métropolitain permettront évidemment
d'aider encore plus nos concitoyens à
avoir un contact avec l'État territorial
enfin nous avons réglé dans l'année 2023
grâce à la mobilisation notamment de la
ministre Dominique fort la question la
délivrance des titres d'identité et de
voyage avec 15 millions d'euros puis 48
millions d'euros donné aux collectivités
locales et aux préfectures pour résoudre
ces difficultés évidemment inacceptables
en service public publ pour les français
puisque plus personne n'en parle
aujourd'hui monsieur le Président je
veux dire que le délai de rendez-vous en
mairie est désormais de 19 jours contre
77 voilà 1 an et demi ce n'est que juste
service public rendu à nos concitoyens
3è point le ministère se projette sur
les événements de 2024 et singulièrement
en dehors des événements qui sont ceux
du débarquement de Normandie ou de
Provence c'est des événements habituels
que va connaître notre pays les
l'événement majeur c'est bien sûr les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques à la
fois dans les plans antidélinquan dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme dans
l'organisation hors norme 30 sites 200
cation 32 sports 329 épreuves 31500
volontaires qu'il nous faut évidemment
passer au fichier 26000 journalistes
accrédités et plus de 100 millions de
spectateurs cumulés attendus en
île-de-fance mais c'est partout les Jeux
Olympiques monsieur bonduit c'est à la
fois châteurou c'est à la fois à
Marseille ce sera évidemment aussi à
Tahiti puisque nous avons également les
épreuves de surf puisque le surf est né
en Polynésie française et n'est pas né à
Hawai qu'on se le dise bien sûr 35000
forces de l'ordre seront donc engagé
pour accueillir du 26 juillet au 8
septembre 2024 les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à ce jour pour répondre à
une question que vous manquerez pas de
me poser c'est 200 millions d'euros le
surcût des Jeux Olympiques pour le
ministère de de l'Intérieur évidemment
dans le budget que nous prévoyons il y
aura l'occasion de revenir évidemment
une fois que l'événement sera passé un
dispositif ministériel d'envergure qui
n'a pas d'équival au ministère de de
l'Intérieur enfin sur le volet sécurité
routière qui dépend des des crédits du
ministère de l'Intérieur un programme
207 qui connaî là aussi une hausse
inédite de ses crédits qui passe de 35
millions d'euros à de 35 millions
d'euros pardon en crédit de paiement ce
qui n'a évidemment pour plein de sujets
notamment l'augmentation des crédits
pour lutter contre le la conduite sous
stupéfiant vous le vous en rappelez a
permis bien sûr d'être au rendez-vous de
nos concitoyens voilà monsieur le
Président vous dire
votre convocation pré pas les crédits
qui rel de la mission immigration et
donc ce sera la semain
prochaine l'honneur de vous les
présenter merci la parole est à Monsieur
Thomas rig rapporteur pour avis de la
mission
sécurité merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur
chers collègues nous sommes réunis cet
après-midi afin d'examiner pour avis les
crédit de la mission sécurité en ce qui
concerne en tant que rapporteur pour
avis des programmes police nationale
gendarmerie nationale et éducation et
sécurité routière dans le cadre du PLF
2024 plus que jamais à l'heure où notre
pays et nos voisins européens sont
confrontés à une multitude de menaces le
renforcement de notre arsenal
sécuritaire par des moyens législatifs
et financier est indispensable à cet
égard je ne peux commencer mes chers
collègues cette présentation sans avoir
une pensée pour Monsieur Dominique
Bernard enseignant assassiné il y a
quelques jours dans son lycée par un
terroriste islamiste et aussi
également pour les deux ressortissants
suédois assassinés par un fanatique
islamiste hier à Bruxelles notre lutte
pour venir à bout de ce fléo doit donc
être
inébranlable le budget présenté par
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur
s'inscrit dans une trajectoire en hausse
constante depuis 2017 et qui s'amplifie
depuis le début de cette législature les
crédits de paiement affectés à la police
nationale observent ainsi une
augmentation de plus de 4.5 % et s'élève
à 12.9 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement ceux de la gendarmerie
nationale progresse de la même façon et
atteignent près de 10.4 milliards
d'euros l'ordre de grandeur n'est pas
comparable concernant l'éducation et la
sécurité routière mais cette mission
bénéficie également d'une très forte
revalorisation à hauteur de 109 millions
d'euros pour 2024 soit une hausse de
plus de 46%. au total les budgets de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
présentent donc une hausse cumulée de
plus de 1 milliard d'euros par rapport à
l'année précédente cette évolution
témoigne de votre engagement monsieur le
ministre du gouvernement et de notre
majorité parlementaire a renforcer
puissamment et durablement les moyens
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité de
nos compatriotes de métropole mais aussi
d'outre maire la loi du 24 janvier 2023
appelée l'opmi approuvée à une très
large majorité par l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat s'inscrit pleinement dans
cette perspective ce sont plus de 2000
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
qui s'ajouteront l'année prochaine aux
effectifs actuels nous l'avons dit et
répété vous l'avez encore dit Monsieur
le Ministre la présence accrue des bleus
sur le terrain n'est pas un slogan ou un
ve pieux c'est plus que jamais une
réalité je ne rentrerai pas mes chers
collègues dans le détail de la
répartition des crédits au sein de
chaque programme et de leur action
puisque monsieur Darmanin a déjà
présenté un tableau précis des
ressources humaines et matérielles dont
disposeront nos forces de sécurité
l'année prochaine cette année 2024 sera
marquée bien évidemment par
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à Paris et bien au-delà la
sécurisation de cet événement planétaire
constitue donc un enjeu colossal à
l'heure où la menace terroriste se situe
encore à un niveau très élevé et
malheureusement les événements tragiques
de ces derniers jours ne le rappellent
cruellement à cet égard je souhaiterais
attirer votre attention monsieur le
ministre sur deux points en particulier
premièrement la loi du 24 janvier 2022 a
créé la réserve opérationnelle au sein
de la police nationale avec un objectif
ambitieux de 30000 réservices à
l'horizon 2030 dont 70 % issu de la
société civile près d'un an après son
lancement pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre vous indiquer combien de réserv
sont été recrutés à ce jour le nombre de
vacations réalisées et plus généralement
quel premier bilan pouvez-vous tirer de
ces débuts deuxièmement la loi du 19 mai
2023 relative aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques a autorisé le recours à
titre expérimental de traitement
algorithmique dans le but de déceler
selon un cadre très strict et nous y
avons suffisamment débattu dans
l'hémicycle il y a quelques mois de cela
des événements anormaux filmés par des
caméras de vidéo protection est
susceptible de présenter un risque pour
la sûreté et la sécurité des personnes
un décret d'application a été récemment
publié exactement le 28 août dernier
pouvez-vous nous fournir quelques
indications sur l'état d'avancement des
procédures de marché ainsi que le
calendrier et le contenu des phases de
test préalables à la mise en œuvre de
ces
technologies outre l'analyse de
l'évolution des crédits de la mission
sécurité j'ai choisi de consacrer cette
année la partie thématique de mon
rapport pour avis aux missions de la
police scientifique exercé tant par les
agents de la police nationale que par
les militaires et les civils de la
gendarmerie nationale la police
scientifique a pour objectif d'aider à
l'identification des auteurs
d'infraction délictuelles et criminelles
grâce à des techniques de recueil et
d'analyse de traces et d'indice mais
elle intervient aussi dans beaucoup
d'autres domaine par exemple pour
identifier les victimes de catastrophes
il s'agit d'une mission décisive afin
d'élicider un nombre toujours plus
important d'affaires concrètement son
activité représente chaque année
l'intervention la réalisation pardon
d'une intervention toutes les 2 minutes
grâce à la production de plus d'un
million d'analyses les experts de la
gendarmerie et de la police se déploient
ainsi sur de multiples de terrain que ce
soit la balistique la biologie ou le
numérique il représente donc un élément
clé d'une police et d'une gendarmerie
moderne et efficace si les progrès de la
technologie peuvent offrir de nouvelles
opportunités pour les délinquants et les
réseaux criminels il constittu également
un atout précieux afin de faciliter les
investigations judiciaires comme nos
collègues latombe et goselin l' avait
souligné dans leur rapport d'information
sur les images de sécurité ces nouveaux
enjeux se dessinent autour de la
manipulation d'imagees ou de son ce que
l'on appelle le Deep fake la lutte
contre ces phénomènes en pleine
expansion nécessite de forts
investissements matériel mais aussi
humain mes chers collègues il est
impératif que nos équipes de police
scientifiqu autant dans la police que
dans la gendarmerie soient doté de des
meilleurs ingénieurs et informaticiens
afin de détecter ces pratiques qui
peuvent nourrir des chantages et des
escroqueries à grande échelle je me suis
déplacé dans le cadre de cette mission à
Pontoise à l'Institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie nationale
et à éculie dans la région le neise au
au service national de la police
scientifique j'ai pu mesurer la
compétence le professionnalisme et le
dévouement de tous les personnels civils
comme militair qui composent l'IRCGN et
le SNPs leur projection au-delà de nos
frontière comme récemment en Ukraine ou
à Beyrou montrre que leur excellence est
reconnue dans le monde entier je tiens
cependant à insister sur un point qui
concerne le recrutement de profils très
spécialisés monsieur le ministre
notamment en matière informatique il me
paraît nécessaire de consacrer un effort
budgétaire supplémentaire pour réduire
l'écart de rémunération existant avec le
secteur privé en utilisant par exemple
le volet indemnitaire ce qui permettra
d'attirer et surtout ensuite de
fidéliser de jeunes ingénieurs et
informaticiens à leur sortie d'école la
lopmie a utilement permis de simplifier
le cadre procédural dans lequel agit la
police scientifique au-delà des des
assouplissements juridiques les
ressources humaines et matérielles dont
bénéficie l'irgpn et le SNPs sont l'une
des garanties majeures de l'
l'efficacité des missions que mène
l'ensemble de nos forces de l'ordre de
sécurité intérieure nous devons mes
chers collègues en être pleinement
conscience conscient je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur je donne la
parole à votre collègue rapporteur pour
avis du programme Sécurité Civile
Monsieur éc
pooget merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens avant de présenter
ce ce rapport pour avis pour la 2e année
consécutive à saluer et à remercier pour
leur engagement l'ensemble de nos forces
de secours au sein bien sûr de la
sécurité civile mais en particulier nos
nos pompiers professionnels et nos
pompiers volontaires au sein de nos 10
dans chacun de nos territoires ce
rapport va se consacrer une première
partie pour l'analyse des du budget les
crédit du programme sécurité civile
s'élève à 734,6 million d'euros en haose
de 2,9 % par rapport à à l'exc à
l'exercice précédent une augmentation de
l'ordre de 0,3 % prenant en compte la
perspective d'inflation mais je veux
rappeler que ces crédits était en forte
augmentation l'année dernière et pour
l'année 2024 il s'incrit d'ailleurs dans
la tendance à la hausse des crédits que
nous avons voté lors de la lopmi à cet
instant je tiens à saluer monsieur le
ministre l'annonce des 140 millions
d'euros supplémentaires que vous venez
de faire qui vont se répartir entre 45
millions d'euros pour la création de la
4e unité d'instruction de sécurité
civile qui s'installera à Libourne
163 etetp donc temps plein 39 millions
d'euros au titre des pactes capacitaires
qui viennent irriguer notre département
et 32 millions d'euros pour les
canadaires et 23 millions d'euros pour
la location de moyens aériens avion
hélicoptères et bombardier d'eau euh le
le programme sécurité civile se
décompose vous le savez en quatre
missions prévention et gestion des
crises préparation et intervention des
moyens nationaux qui euh emporte les
montants les plus importants soutien aux
acteurs de la sécurité civile et enfin
fonction soutien et logistique le
programme 161 ne représente en réalité
qu'une faible part du budget total de la
sécurité civile qui s'élève qui s'élevé
l'an passé à plus de 7 milliards d'euros
de manière consolidée le budget global
de la sécurité civile est principalement
assumé par les collectivités territorial
en particulier par les départements qui
sont les principaux financeurs de ces
services des services d'incendie et de
secours d'où l'intérêt de se pencher sur
le financement des10 et donc de nos
moyens de sécurité civile dans l'avenir
le nombre de licitation des 10 ne cesse
de croître il s'estélevé à 4,7 millions
en 2021 contre près de 5 millions en
2022 dont les 3 quart pour du secours à
victimes cette augmentation continue
continue de la charge desd est ainsi
largement supporté par les collectivité
territoriale pourtant financièrement à
bout de souffle pour répondre à cette
importante demande d'assistance et de
secours la France devra compter 20000
sapeurs pompiers volontaires et 50000
professionnels en 2027 et investir
lourdement en matériel pour accompagner
ces nouveaux déploiements et moderniser
l'action de nos pompiers d'où la
nécessité de réfléchir à de nouvelles
sources de financement de notre modèle
de sécurité civile et ça ça me permet de
faire la transition et de vous présenter
le thème que j'ai choisi pour ce rapport
j'ai choisi de faire un un éclairage
particulier sur une notion un petit peu
novatrice dans le domaine de la sécurité
civile qui est la valeur du sauveré une
notion qui est nouvelle qui est l'objet
d'étude académique depuis plusieurs
années un concept qui est utilisé
principalement dans le domaine de la
lutte contre l'incend dit qui vise à
quantifier les avantages économiques
résultants des interventions des S10 et
des pompiers cette ces études reposent
sur la différence entre les dommages
réels constatés lors d'incident et la
valeur totale des vies des biens et de
l'environnement qui ont été préservés
grâce à l'action de nos pompiers 27 10
actuellement en France propose ce mode
de calcul sur une ou plusieurs
opérations de la valeur du sauvé je
remercie notamment les représentants des
10 des bouches du Ron de l'héro et du
Loir que j'ai auditionné et qui m'ont
présenté leur propres méthode de calcul
un groupe de travail que vous avez
initié monsieur le ministre au sein de
la Direction générale de la sécurité
civile a été mis en place le mois
dernier et rassemble les représentants
de 10 expérimentateurs et des
personnalités qualifiées pour travailler
sur cette notion encore prospective je
recommande que ce groupe de travail
élabore des indicateurs communs ainsi
qu'une méthodologie uniforme de calcul
de la valeur du sauvé pour être efficace
le groupe de travail doit associer plus
largement toutes les parties prenantes
en particulier les assureurs qui
financec vous le savez les 10 via la
collete de la TSCA et qui sont
disponibles pour participer à une telle
démarche mais aussi les élus locaux et
notamment représentants des départements
et des communes les réflexions en cours
sur la valeur du sauvé pourraient
nourrir les débats sur l'évolution du
financement des 10 trois pistes
développées dans mon avis d'abord la clé
de répartition de la part dynamique de
la TSCA devrait être modernisée des
travaux sont en cours à ce sujet ils
doivent prendre en compte des critères
qualitatifs comme la valeur du sauvé
afin de mieux répartir partir cette
ressource parmi les 10 deuxième piste je
souhaite également que puisse être
expertisé et le cas échéant mis en place
un fond alimenté par une contribution
générale des assurances reposant
notamment sur la valeur du sauv monsieur
le ministre ma première question est la
suivante les deux recommandations que je
viens de présenter figure dans le
rapport d' Falco qui a été remis au
Président de la République il y a
quelques mois quelle appréciation
portez-vous sur chacune d'entre elles
plus largement pouvez-vous nous indiquer
l'état des négociations avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes concernant
l'évolution du modèle de financement
des1 quel suite le gouvernement
compte-il donner au rapport de l'IGA
prévu par la loi matras à ce sujet et
finalement transmis en fin d'année
dernière au Parlement ENF dernière piste
s'agissant de la TSCA est actuellement
reversée à plusieurs bénéficiaires dont
les départements la Caisse nationale des
allocations familale et la Caisse
Nationale d'Assurance ves une fraction
supplémentaire de la TSCA pourrait être
transférée au département au titre du
financement des 10 je rappelle que les
carences ambulancières sont en haose de
90 % entre 2012 et 2021 représent près
de 6 650000 interventions monsieur le
ministre seriez-vous favorable à une
telle évolution enfin la valeur du
sauveré peut constituer un cas simple et
pédagogique de visualisation et de
valorisation de l'action publique pour
nos concitoyens de nos services de
secours et donc de nos pompiers une
autre illustration concrète pourrait
être par exemple le versement d'une part
de la taxe de séjour au département
touristique au titre du financement des
services d'incendie de secours la
prestation proposée par nos sapeurs
pompiers a de la valeur cette valeur
représente un coût que usager pourrait
prendre en charge pour sa sécurité
monsieur le ministre quel regard
portez-vous sur la notion de valeur du
sauver dont je mesure le caractère
encore expérimental à ce stade mais que
j'estime prometteuse pour l'avenir et
quelle place pourrait-elle occuper dans
le cadre des débats actuels sur le
financement de nos services d'incendie
et de secours je vous
remercie merci on va passer aux orateurs
des groupes je rappelle que les orateurs
des groupes ont 4 minutes et que ceux
qui poseront des questions auront 2
minutes pour la suite alors le premier
orateur de groupe monsieur remémy
reberot pour le groupe Renaissance vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre dans le contexte
que nous connaissons je veux rendre
hommage à mon tour à Dominique Bernard
et aux deux victimes hier originaires de
Suède victime tous les trois du
terrorisme islamique 2024 sera la 2e
année de mise en œuvre de la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur dont de monter
en puissance des effectifs et des moyens
tout en poursuivant la valorisation des
personnels en place et les équipements
prévus antérieurement ce seront 2184
équivalent temp plein supplémentairire
toute force de l'ordre confondu de
nouvelles brigades et de nouvelles
unités de force mobile ce sera aussi
vous l'avez rappelé une année marquée
par les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
en France concernant la police nationale
le programme 176 il s'agit de poursuivre
la réorganisation territoriale sous
commandement unique pour plus
d'efficacité il est prévu également le
recrutement de 1139 policiers
supplémentaires et de continuer la
modernisation des équipements deux
questions parmi les filières métiers il
y a le renseignement notamment à travers
la
DGSI sera-t-il encore renforcé deuxème
question au vu des événements ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il faille encore
accélérer la croissance des effectifs
qui doivent atteindre 8500 emplois
supplémentaire sur le mandat pour la
gendarmerie c'est le programme 152 vous
proposez une augmentation du budget de
4,82 % pour atteindre près de 11
milliards d'euros en 2024 la création de
238 brigades supplémentaires pour
couvrir le territoire de cette unité
mobile la hausse des moyens sur la
cybercriminalité et la lutte contre les
atteintes à l'environnement la
croissance de la réserve et des
politiques de prévention avec là encore
pour fond la sécurisation des des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en France en
2024 une question les représentants des
forces de sécurité intérieure
souhaiterit la défiscalisation
exceptionnelle des heures
supplémentaires pour faciliter la
mobilisation au moment des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique et compléter
le dispositif déployé est-ce que c'est
dans vos intentions concernant la
sécurité routière le programme 207 une
question où en êtes-vous de la réforme
du permis de conduire et des
conséquences des très petits
dépassements de vitesse sur le permis à
point enfin le programme 161 porte sur
la sécurité civile et la gestion des
crises dont la direction monte en en
puissance il comprend l'achat d'aéronef
bombardier d'eau et le soutien au 10
pour faire face aux incendies suite à la
loi nouvelle de juillet dernier 2024
sera aussi le 3e budget depuis la loi
Matrass ça a été rappelé avec un recul
heureux des carences sur le terrain une
question la loi d'orientation prévoyait
l'exonération de l'ex TICPE pour sur les
véhicules sur les carburants des
véhicules des 10 elle a été emise dans
la première version du PLF 2024 elle
devait être rétablie serace le cas au
total C questions et une curiosité
puisque le temps m'en laisse la
possibilité qu'allez-vous faire
exactement suite au propos matinau de
madame auonau qui a rendu un bien
choquant hommage à un mouvement
terroriste
international merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour vos réponses on s'écoute
monsieur Monsieur Thomas menager pour le
groupe rassemblement national merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la France est endeuillée par un
éè épisode de cette triste saga
meurtrière causé par des étrangers
dangereux présents sur notre sol après
la décapitation de samintelpatti la
sauvagerie de l'assassinat de Lola voilà
que les crimes commis par des étrangers
souvent en situation irrégulière
continuent de se profiler devant
l'incapacité du gouvernement à protéger
la population vendredi le professeur
Dominique Bernard a été poignardé par un
Tchen au cri d'Allah Akbar comme ces
milliers d'étrangers fichs autant de
potentielles bombes humaines cet homme
ainsi que sa famille ont pu circuler
librement sur le territoire alors qu'il
présentait de sérieuses menaces pour la
vie des français malgré cela vous avez
été incapable de voir la barbarie avant
qu'elle n'explose une nouvelle fois aux
yeux de lycéens et de personnel de
l'enseignement j'avais sollicité comme
ça a été dit par le Président houier au
nom du groupe rassemblée nationale que
nous puissions vous auditionner
spécifiquement pour lever le voile sur
les défaillances de l'État ayant mené à
ce drame malheureusement ce temps qui
aurait dû nous permettre d'obtenir
toutes les réponses auxquelles les
Français attendent des réponses depuis
des années n'ont pas pu être posé
puisque vous n'avez pas donné ce ce
moment et et je le regrette vous
indiquez hier sur les 20120 inscrits au
fsprt qu'il y a 1411 individus qui sont
en situation irrégulière mais vous
n'avez donné aucun chiffre sur les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que sur les personnes qui ont été
récemment naturalisé est-ce qu'il serait
possible pour vous de nous communiquer
ce chiffre aujourd'hui vous avez enfin
annoncé samedi dernier que vous étiez
favorable à l'expulsion systématique de
tout étranger considéré comme dangereux
par les renseignant
nous salons bien entendu cette nouvelle
ligne mais nous sommes néanmoins
accablés de voir le temps que vous avez
mis pour ouvrir les yeux et au bout du
compte tout ce temps perdu au-delà des
crédits prévus par la lopmie que nous
avons soutenu le principal reste la
volonté politique et je m'interroge
réellement monsieur le minist sur votre
volonté à combattre en profondeur le
fondamentalisme islamisme comme nous le
proposons avec Marine Le Pen comme l'a
dit aujourd'hui Michel paatti la sœur de
Samuel Patti si des mesures avaient été
prises après l'attentat qui avait coûté
la vie à son frère Dominique Bernard
serait encore là ce sont les propos de
la sœur de Samuel Paty est-ce que vous
avez une réponse à apporter à cette
femme et ne pensez-vous pas monsieur le
ministre que les atermoimement du
gouvernement à mettre l'immigration au
cœur des débats de notre assemblée ont
au final empêché de faire émerger
l'arsenal législatif qui aurait été
capable de lutter contre l'islamisme
radical puisqu'il s'agit de cela et les
fléaux de cette immigration incontrôlé
et que euh ce travail législative aurait
pu permettre au final que le sang ne
coule pas à nouveau sur notre
sol madame Misa Martin pour le groupe la
France insoumise merci beaucoup de nous
donner la parole je veux d'abord
commencer par une remarque à caractère
général monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outresmères vous
indiquez que ce budget est orienté
contre la délinquence du quotidien et
dans l'objectif de doubler la présence
des fonctionnaire sur la voie publique
permettez-nous de contester cet objectif
et de vous dire que en tout cas ils
n'ont pas de sens sans des des officiers
de police judiciaire suffis en nombre
suffisant ils sont 6000 aujourd'hui qui
permettraiit effectivement de lutter
d'une façon efficace contre le trafic
les les je parle évidemment du des
services liés à la police judiciaire en
tant que tel donc en nom suffisant il
s'agit bien de 6000 et de surcroix tout
à fait indépendant et l'on sait que via
la
départementalisation vous les mettez
contre leur avis unanime sous lesgides
des préfets mais ça n'est pas sur ce
point-là que nous voulons attirer votre
attention et attirer le débat c'est sur
la question de la formation d'abord nous
nous arrêtons initial et continue
d'abord arrêtons-nous un instant sur les
chiffres
nous nous sommes rendus compte que
relativement aux dépenses inscrites ce
qui a été engagé c'est-à-dire ce qui a
été finalement dépensé a été divisé par
2 en 2022 entre ce qui est inscrit et ce
qui est effectivement dépensé or ce qui
nous intéresse vous vous en doutez bien
comme tous ceux qui sont susceptibles de
nous écouter c'est la réalité des prix
c'est-à-dire effectivement ce qui a été
dépensé de surcroix ce qui paraît être
engagé ce qui paraît être annoncé
toujours sur ces crédits que je peux
pointer bien sûr précisément il s'agit
de l'action
06-01 formation dans le programme 176 de
la police nationale et bien ce qui est
projeté c'est une baisse de
34,1 %. alors que va-t-il se passer quel
va être effectivement les moyens quels
vont être effectivement les moyens
financiers qui vont être mobilisés dans
cet objectif de formation
ce budget est-il sincère que quelle
conclusion pouvons-nous effectivement en
tirer nous descendons dans les étages
nous constatons que il y a zéro
engagement en ce qui concerne le
maintien de l'ordre et donc la formation
au maintien de l'ordre alors que l'on
sait que ce sont des effectifs formés
comme les CRS qui permettent parce
qu'ils sont dans un souci de
coordination en particulier et parce
qu'ils savent concrètement agir en terme
de maintien de l'ordre sont responsables
de bien moins de violence que les bacs
qui ont été mobilisés par exemple
pendant la réforme des retraites et qui
n'ont pas c'est ainsi la formation pour
le faire et pour agir de bonne manière
rien sur les violences sexistes et
sexuelles malgré tous vos engagements
malgré les engagements du garde des saut
sur l'accueil sur le suivi de ces
victimes qui sont des victimes très
particulières et j'ose vous rappeler
bien que vous le sachiez évidemment que
le nombre de féminicides dans notre pays
ne baisse pas or l'on sait que la
qualité de l'accueil et de leur suivi a
un impact direct sur les dépôts de
plaines ça veut dire sur la prévention
générale de ce type de situation et bien
évidemment puisque c'est délicat cela
suppose de la formation idem en ce qui
concerne le recrutement vous ne nous
dites pas où est la dizaine d'écoes qui
est fermée ce que vous voulez enfer vous
avez réallongé effectivement le durée de
la durée de formation mais il y avait
introduit le temps d'OPJ la formation au
gestes technique professionnel est
importante mais n'est pas nécessaire et
c'est de ils doivent être armés sur un
plan théorique pour faire face à la
complexité du monde et résister à la
nomie qui parfois les étreint et qui
explique le nombre important de la
parole est à Monsieur Yan Bouard pour le
groupe les républicains excellent merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre nous étudions aujour'hui le
budget pour 2024 de la sécurité sujet
central pour les Français dans cette
période marquée par un accroissement
d'insécurité le retour des actes
terroristes sur notre territoire la
sécurité est un pouvoir régalien et la
responsabilité du législateur de
l'assurer en votant un budget suffisant
pour nos forces de l'ordre je tiens
d'ailleurs à le rendre hommage pour le
travail qu'ils accomplit chaque jour et
et leur assure que le groupe les
républicain protègera toujours ceux qui
nous protègeent le budget sécurité que
nous propose aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur augmente et
cette augmentation est le résultat du
vote par notre assemblée n l'OPIE
ambitieux sur laquelle le groupe les
républicains a pu obtenir de nombreuses
avancées en faveur de l'amélioration des
des conditions d'exercice de nos forces
de l'ordre pour autant la France reste
un pays où la délinquence et la
criminalité plus élevé que dans la
moyenne des pays de l'Union européenne
et les statistiques de l'année 2022
confirment cette tendance plus 8 %
d'homicide plus 15 % pour les cûs et
blessures volontaires et plus 11 % pour
les violences sexuelles la faute en
partie une réponse judiciaire non
adaptée qui encourage la récidive et un
manque riant de place de prison en
matière de sécurité je dénonce depuis 6
ans le en même temps au sein duquel le
chef de l'État n'a jamais su trancher
l'augmentation de la présence des forces
ors sur la voie publique est une bonne
mesure et celle-ci devrait doubler d'ici
10 ans il est effectivement proposé que
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie bénéficient d'un schéma
d'emploi de plus 2184 équivalent en
plein en 2024 des moyens supplémentaires
sont alloués pour répondre à des enjeux
sécuritaires nouveaux tels que la
filière cyber ou les avancé concernant
les violences intrafamiliales avec la
création de 99 maisons de protection des
familles nous sommes également
évidemment favorables au renouvellement
des moyens de maintien de l'ordre et
d'intervention à l'image de la
densification des pelotons de
surveillance et d'intervention de la
gendarmerie du renouvellement
de l'équipement de la police nationale
et des moyens mobiles des deux forces
enfin ce budget en augmentation est
inévidablement marqué par le défi que
représente l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques à Paris cela
impliquera des mesures importantes
telles que la densification des
équipements qui permettra aux forces de
gendarmerie et de police d'assurer dans
les meilleures conditions la
sécurisation du plus grand événement
sportif mondial après le fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale Ligue des
champions de football le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre n'a pas le droit de
ridiculiser une nouvelle fois notre pays
sur la scène internationale j'en viens
aux questions que je souhaite vous poser
monsieur le ministre ministre en
prolongement de mon propos en premier
lieu sur les difficultés de recrutement
chez les forces de l'ordre ce budget
2024 est en effet un nuancé notamment au
regard de la sous-consommation chronique
des crédits budgétaires de personnel
pour la mission sécurité dans son
rapport d'analyse de l'exécution
budgétaire 2022 paru en avril 2023 la
Cour des comptes relève une
sous-consommation des crédits personnels
qui est causé par les difficultés de
recrutement et de fidélisation qui
s'accroissent vous affichez 2100
nouveaux postes de gendarmes sur le
quinquen mais certaines sources au sein
de de votre ministère évoque le chiffre
de 3000 départs non prévus rien que pour
l'année 2023 comme évoqué le JDD de son
édition du 15 octobre ces difficultés à
fidéliser les Agen se conjuguent aux
difficultés de recrutement auprès des
jeunes générations qui s'explique en
grande parti par la dégradation des
conditions de travail elle démontre
également que les seules revalorisations
indemnitaires ne suffisent plus à
fidéliser les effectifs aussi
pourriez-vous nous présenter la
stratégie et les mesures que le
Gouvernement entend déployer pour
répondre à ce défi alors où nos forces
de l'ordre sont de plus en plus
sollicitées et alors que les enjeux
sécuritaires ne cessent de s'aggraver je
veux conclure monsieur le ministre en
évoquant la menace terroriste quelques
jours après l'attentat qui eu lieu au
lycée gambet d'as pouvez-nous vous
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur les
conditions qui ont permis un
ressortissant étranger fich S et qui
aurait dû être expulsé de demeurer en
France et de commettre cet attentat
insupportable le projet de loi
immigration qui doit être débattu en
cette fin d'année notre assemblée
n'aurait rien changé puisqu'il n'aurait
en réalité pas permis l'expulsion du
terroriste Mohamed mogchov en effet il
ne propose que des modifications timides
du régime de protection des étrangers y
compris lorsqu'il représente une menace
pour l'ordre public je connais la
mobilisation de nos services de
renseignement et de nos forces de
l'ordre pour protéger nos compatriotes
de ces Barb je connais monsieur le
ministre votre mobilisation personnelle
mais l'intensification de la menace
terroriste mériste une plus grande
fermeté et les Français réclament à
juste titre l'enfermement de tous ceux
représentant une menace terroriste ou
leur expulsion s'ils sont étrangers
quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre pour
mieux combattre la menace terroriste et
surtout comment comptez-vous convaincre
ceux au sein de votre majorité dont
madame la Première ministre qui vous ont
contraint à décaler ce projet de loi de
plusieurs mois que sur ce sujet l'heure
n'est plus à la procrastination coupable
ou à l'angélisme mais à la fermeté en
adoptant notamment la révision
constitutionnelle proposée par les
républicains qui nous permettrait
d'expulser ces ces individus qui
représentent une menace pour les
Français merci pour votre information le
projet de loi est inscrit le 11 décembre
à ma connaissance à le calendrier de
l'Assemblée nationale madame Blandine
brocard pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues
permettez-moi tout d'abord de souligner
l'importance cruciale du budget que nous
examinons aujourd'hui pour la mission
sécurité dans un contexte si dramatique
les crédits reflètent la mise en œuvre
des principes et objectifs énoncés dans
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur que nous
avons adoptés en décembre 2022 ces
objectifs nous le savons sont bien plus
que de simples lignes directrices ils
incarnent la transformation
significative de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure qui aura un impact direct sur
la vie de nos concitoyens et cela
renforce encore davantage la confiance
des Français envers ceux qui les
protègent parfois au péril de leur vie
ne l'oublions jamais le risque
terroriste la délinquence du quotidien
les violences intrafamiliales les zones
de non droit que la République doit
impérativement reconquérir y compris
l'espace numérique nécessite une
présente notablement renforcée de nos
forces de sécurité sur le terrain une
présence qui se traduit ici par la
création de plus de 2000 équivalents
temp plein supplémentaires en 2024 en
complément des
2857 déjà engagés cette année il est
indispensable que nos policiers et
gendarmes puissent assurer leur mission
première être sur le terrain au plus
près des Français pour les libérer des
tâches administrative de l'étouffante
paperasserie qui leur fait perdre un
temps précieux d'action en étant enfermé
dans leur bureau comme ils disent eux
même nous misons sur le développement de
solutions numériques innovantes
l'accélération des procédures et le
déploiement des assistants d'enquête
dans les brigades libéré de ces
contraintes nos forces de sécurité
pourront se consacrer pleinement à leur
mission vitale protéger nos concitoyens
préserver nos instition et garantir le
respect inébranlable de la loi
l'objectif est clair et ambitieux
doubler la présence opérationnelle sur
le terrain dans les 10 prochaines années
et réduire de manière significative dès
l'année prochaine ces missions
périphériques qui entravent l'efficacité
de nos
unités je tiens à souligner que les
crédits alloués au chapitre 152 pour la
gendarmerie et 176 pour la police
nationale témoigne d'une forte
détermination à combattre et à prévenir
la délinquence sous toutes ses formes
qu'il s'agisse de la délin du quotidien
des réseaux et filières criminelles et
terroristes de l'économie souterraine ou
de toute forme de délinquence numérique
en raccourcissant les délais
d'intervention en systématisant l'apport
de solutions techniques et scientifiques
nous souhaitons optimiser de manière
continue l'efficacité des enquêtes une
présence renforcée également sur le
terrain numérique avec la formation et
le déploiement de cyber patrouilleurs
qui permettront je l'espère de mettre un
nécessaire terme aux dérives qui font de
l'espace virtuel le terrain privilégié
du harcell de trafic et arnaqu en tout
genre de la radicalisation et de la
diffusion de violence et de haine mes
questions quant à elle monsieur le
ministre concerne le logement de nos
forces de l'ordre vous le savez monsieur
le ministre je suis particulièrement
engagé pour que nos gendarmes soi logé
en sécurité et de manière à minima
correcte quelles sont les actions qui
seront menées cette année pour nos
casernes et comment permettre aussi à
tous nos policiers de se loger à
proximité de leur commissariat à des
loyers raisonnables même quand quand
c'est en plein centre-ville je vous
remercie merci monsieur Roger Vicot pour
le groupe socialiste oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs nous nous
livrons un exercice à la fois légitime
et étrange légitime parce qu'évidemment
il est tout à fait logique et normal de
de se pencher sur ligne par ligne sur
ces proposition budgétaire et étrange
parce que nous le faisons dans un
contexte qui parfois peut laisser
paraître dérisoire certaines de
certaines des
expressions qui sont qui sont données
ici moi je suis pas soupçonnable d'être
proche politiquement de monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur mais lorsque
j'entends ici a quelques instants qu'il
est soupçonné de ne n'avoir pas la
volonté de lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme islamiste je me dis que la
parole politique mériterait d'être
parfois ici à un niveau de crédibilité
différent je voulais le dire en
préambule parce que euh ça a arraché
chez moi un enè soupire quand j'entends
ce genre de chos mais je voulais dire
parce que à un moment donné voilà s'il y
a un mot qui est utile peut-être et
légitime dans la situation que nous
livons c'est probablement le mot unité
euh et unité face à ce qui est mis en
place et et et et et pour nous et pour
l'ensemble des Français alors sur le sur
le bleu budget enfin sur les sur les
propositions budgétaires moi je voudrais
intervenir sur quelques points en
particulier notamment sur la question de
la formation il a été beaucoup question
de la formation pendant la la lopm et
d'ailleurs chacun des groupes qui a
discuté de la lopmie était d'accord sur
le fait que cette question de la
formation était extrêmement importante
alors l'objectif qui est affiché comme
l'an dernier d'ailleurs est est
d'augmenter le temps de formation Contin
continu de de 50 % et je constate que
alors sauf erreur de ma part
euh le budget pour 2024 prévoit 0 ETP
euh sur la formation alors comment
fait-on pour à la fois augmenter le
temps de formation de 50 % et 0 ETP
alors je sais que les policiers déjà en
place peuvent devenir eux-mêmes
formateurs et cetera et cetera mais au
regard des effectifs qui augmentent
parce qu'on est à je crois 1000 1000
1000 1000 1000 et quelques 1200 1184 TP
en plus il me semble que la question de
la formation aurait mérité un effort
supplémentaire sur la cybersécurité on
l'a aussi beaucoup évoqué pendant la
lopmie pendant les débats de la lopmie
c'est un sujet extrêmement important
contte tenu des des des des des moyens
de de de guerre par sécurité aujourd'hui
euh par cybersécurité aujourd'hui pardon
et le texte de 2024 est à la virgule
près le texte 2023 il nous dit pour
faire face au nouvelle forme de
délinquence le nombre de C patouyeurs
sera augmenté alors que vient d'être
mise en place un centre national de
formation cyber qui assure la formation
connue des enquêteurs et on n'en sait
pas beaucoup plus donc si effectivement
la cybersécurité est un thème très
important et je le crois et je crois que
nous sommes tous convaincus de ça ici je
pense que cette question là aurait
mérité d'être davantage développée sur
la sécurité civile monsieur le ministre
vous avez évoqué alors avec justesse le
le le le le défi que représente la
sécurité civile aujourd'hui j'ai bien
noté que le bleu pour 2024 annonce le
renouvellement de la flotte de canadaer
avec une première commande de quatre
appareils dont deux seront financés pour
l'Union européenne ma seule petite
question c'est euh est-ce que nous
sommes certains que ces appareils seront
livrés avant l'été 2024 c'est une vraie
question d'autant plus que enfin j'en
souris mais je ne devrais pas d'autant
plus que l'été démarre malheureusement
de plus en plus tôt avec les les les
conséquences que ça a désormais dans
l'ensemble des régions de France un
dernier point sur le les indicateurs
d'efficacité je note que la gendarmerie
établit ses indicateurs à partir des
directive de la direction
interministérielle pour la
transformation publique autrement dit
les gendarmes ont des indicateurs de
qualité de service public de
satisfaction du public et sur la police
nationale on a que des indicateurs
fondés sur l'intervention hormis
quelques éléments sur le temps d'attente
TS commissariat
merci Monsieur Didier Le Maire pour le
groupe
horison allez-y Monsieur Ma merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
maires chers collègues permettez-moi
tout d'abord de remercier Thomas rudigo
rapporteur pour avis sur le programme
police nationale et gendarmerie
nationale ainsi que éc poer rapporteur
pour avis sur le programme sécurité
civile pour le travail effectué la
mission sécurité regroupe l'ensemble des
moyens financiers relevant du ministère
de l'Intérieur est concourant à la
protection des populations sur tout le
territoire elle poursuit les efforts
engagés dans la lopmie le budget de
cette mission est en hausse pour l'année
2024 notamment sur la partie consacrée à
la sécurité et l'éducation routière à la
police et à la gendarmerie nationale
dans le prolongement des efforts
réalisés depuis 2017 pour améliorer la
sécurité du quotidien sur l' emble du
territoire l'année 2024 sera marquée par
une amplification de la mobilisation et
l'accélération de la modernisation de la
police nationale elle verra s'accroître
la présence des forces de l'ordre sur la
voie publique le groupe horizon salue
d'ailleurs l'annonce de 39 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie qui s'ajoute au
200 prévu par la lopmie dans cette
mission sécurité le programme sécurité
civile porte l'ensemble des politiques
du ministère de l'Intérieur consacré à
la protection des populations et à la
gestion de crise aussi si je me réjouis
que la direction générale de la sécurité
civile et de la gestion des crises
consacre une augmentation importante de
ces moyens opérationnels avec la
création de 200 emplois et 818 millions
d'euros de crédit supplémentaires sur 5
ans je vous interrogais monsieur le
ministre l'année passé sur
l'accompagnement des communes à la
prévention de la population au risque en
général et à l'éducation du risque
incendie en particulier la protection de
la population est en effet l'enjeu de
ces prochains mois face aux différents
risques que nous affronterons qu'il soit
d'origine naturelle technologie
technologique pardon sanitaire et
malheureusement terroriste il est
important d'acculturer nos concitoyennes
et concitoyens à l'échelon le plus juste
aussi je me réjouis de la mise en œuvre
de la journée annuelle de la résilience
face au risque mais également du
renforcement des dispositifs d'alerte à
la population en particulier le SIP avec
l'achat de 2200 nouvelles armoires de
commande permettant un déclenchement via
la 4G adapté à l'arrêt progressif de l'
NPT à compté de 2025 mais aussi de
l'installation de 400 sirènes
supplémentaires pour une mise en service
d'ici 2026 avec une centaine une
centaine prévue en 2024 cependant
j'aimerais savoir Monsieur le Ministre
si ces dispositifs seront accompagnés de
la formation et de la sensibilisation de
la population adéquate et si oui de
quelle façon à ce sujet pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si le système d'alerte fr
alerte qui actionne tous les téléphones
mobiles dans un secteur géographique
donné est disponible et efficace sur
l'intégralité du territoire de notre
pays par ailleurs je me réjouis
également de la mise en place d'un
numéro unique de gestion des appels
d'urgence qui va vers une plus grande
simplicité d'utilisation pour les
usagères et les usagers du service
public pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur
la durée de cette expérimentation et sur
le développement sur l'ensemble du
territoire le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera en faveur de cette
mission budgétaire telle qu'elle est
proposée je vous remercie merci Madame
Sandra regol pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues globalement ce
budget est à la hausse et c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle mais comme souvent le
diable se cache dans les détails je
pense notamment au recul des moyens de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
qui semble traduire en recul de
l'engagement de la présence de l'État
dans les territoires de la baisse des
moyens accordés à l'action numérique du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui rentre en
contradiction avec les engagements de
modernisation pris dans la lopie ou
encore de la baisse des moyens accordés
au fond interministériel de prévention
de la délinquence une baisse des moyens
qui apparaît vraiment comme une anomalie
alors que la prévention de la
délinquence et de la de la
radicalisation pardon devrait être
maintenant plus que jamais alors que la
France est encore en deuillé une
priorité nous demandons au contraire
d'augmenter les moyens plus
spécifiquement les rapports police
population sont souvent questionnés
cornérisant les effectifs dédiés à leur
fonction et dédonnant ceux qui flirt
avec le droit et les agents de police le
plus souvent expriment leur colère en
dehors des syndicats pour faire entendre
des réalités de terrain une réalité qui
est aujourd'hui un enjeu social parce
qu'avec plus de 1000 suicides sur les 20
dernières années il y a euh de quoi agir
alors vous me direz bien qu'il y a 122
psychologues ce qui fait peu tout de
même par rapport aux 150000 agents en
service qu'il existe le dispositif
Sentinel mais les agents sont
régulièrement nommés volontaires
d'office rendant peu effectif leur
travail ou encore qu'il existe un
programme de mobilisation contre le
suicide mais avec 2,9 millions d'euros
dans le PLF 2024 c'est assez peu pour
agir il y a certes une formation à
distance agir pour prévenir le suicide
et ses conséquences mais quand on voit
que le budget dédié à la formation passe
de 43 à 29 millions malgré le
recrutement annoncé de milliers de
nouveaux agents ça n'appelle pas à
l'optimisme nous avons donc déposé des
amendements de demandant de véritabl
moyens de lutte contre le suicide
malheureusement le 493 va venir encore
une fois balayer ses propositions avant
même que le débat puisse avoir lieu il
ve cependant la possibilité de soutenir
ou de discuter avec nous de ces
propositions la la sécurité civile elle
aussi est en première ligne avec le
réchauffement climatique qui augmente à
la fois le risque l'intensité des feux
et et ça demande des moyen à la hauteur
de ce qui constitue l'enjeu du siècle
l'IGA alerte sur le risque de rupture
capacitaire et nous proposons de doubler
ce choc capacitaire dansun fond
d'investissement national permettant
d'accompagner des investissements de
diverses natures notamment pour
renforcer les moyens humains avec des
recrutements massifs de 40000 personnels
d'ici 2035 avec un objectif de 50 % de
professionnel d'ici 2040 une demande
forte chez les sapeurs pompiers de
valoriser leur travail aussi avec un
retour de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 55 ans et une retraite
anticipée pour les volontaires quand ils
ont l'ancienneté de généraliser enfin la
formation au feu de forêt qui doit être
intégré au Tron commun afin de renforcer
aussi les moyens matériels certes vous
prévoyez d'acquérir 1100 nouveau camion
citerne feu de forêt pour attteindre les
100000 mais ce n'est là que revenir au
niveau de 2005 face au risque réel face
à l'enjeu du siècle nous proposons un
objectif de 6000 CCF d'ici 2030 enfin
investir dans les moyens aériens certes
vous le faites mais encore une fois vous
prévoyez des acquisitions qui
représentent un niveau minimal nous vous
proposons un niveau adapté et surtout
d'investir enfin dans des appareils qui
permettent de s'entraîner non pas au
Canada mais de le faire sur place enfin
et je conclurai là-dessus puisque ce
n'est pas l'objet de cette audition il
convient de travailler collectivement au
mode de finance
nous aurons l'occasion de reparler dans
la deuxème partie du PLF de la TSCA ou
de la contribution additionnelle à la
taxe de séjour comme le recommande
notamment notre collègue Florian choche
merci Monsieur David riman pour le
groupe gauche démocrate
républicaine merci monsieur le Président
donc je monsieur le ministre je
commencerai mon mon propos en vous
disant que
euh tous les tous les membres de la
police de la gendarmerie pay et même des
des forces armées en en un but en
général c'est d'éviter les drames sur
notre territoire et lorsqu'il y en a un
qui arrive je pense que la plupart
d'entre eux d'entre son meurtris et et
c'est pour ça quand c en trouble il
faudra il faut avoir le propos mesuré
essayer de l'avoir juste parce qu'on
parle de de vie humaines donc je ne
ferai pas comme certains la course
àéchalotte à déclaration enemptepièce
qui n' est queun tête en ce qui nous
concerne ensuite concernant ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui Monsieur le le
ministre je vaux pas rappeler les
chiffres qui ont largement été commentés
é changé et et dit à par les uns et les
autres mais vraiment tourner autour de
la politique globale qu' tradit au
travers de ces chiffres là et là-dessus
plusieurs questions euh plusieurs
questions nous taraudent dans la mesure
ce qu'on veut vraiment je prends pour
exemple euh on a écrit y a quelques mois
pour demander par rapport aux Jeux
Olympiques euh comment est-ce que allait
se traduire la
réaffectation de différentes par exemple
compagniees de garde mobile tant sur les
territoires autremire que Surire de
l'Hexagone puisque il a il allait
déployer un certain nombre de forces
pour péréniser et garantir la sécurité
durant les Jeux Olympiques on na pas eu
de réponse à cela puce que sachant que
des moyens seront redéployés il y aura
un vide à un moment donné donc comment
cela va être-il être compensé
jusqu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas eu de
réponse à ce sujet derrière je prends
encore pour exemple euh le choix que
fait euh c'est pour ça qu' lorsque nous
parlions au niveau de la lopie le le le
fait de de mettre départementaliser les
les forces donc sous l'gide du préfet
des chat peuvent être faites à
différents moments et je prends exemple
pour le terr que je connais le mieux la
Guyane le préfet mobilise quasiment une
compagnie de garde mobile chaque jour
pour protéger un un
site de porteur de projet privé pour
mener entre guillemets bataille contre
des jeunes aux autochtones la plupart AG
entre 14 15 ans qui défendent quoi qui
défendent leur lieu de vie leur lieu de
chasse leur lieu de subsistance au
quotidien alors qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin de ces forcesl pour lutter contre
le raillage illégal qui je le rappelle
pollue nos mères et nos fleuves et qui
automatiquement a des dégâts sur l'être
humain et sur la faune et la flore DEP
plus de 30 ans pour autant on a toujours
pas trouvé de solution finale vous
connaissez notre posture sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on on doiv passer du du
d'une posture de maintien à une posture
d'irradication du phénomène au-delà de
tout ça il y a les moyens aussi qui sont
plus ou moins mis à différents niveaux
euh je prends par exemple pour le cas
pour la guyan il faudrait un deuxième
hélicoptère pour les forces de
gendarmerie pour mener à bien toutes
leur missions nécessaires sur le
territoire je rappelle que la Guyane
c'est 80 10000 km² et à couvrir sur une
végétation extrêmement dense et donc il
faut les moyens adéquats pour cela pour
pour autant on a pas forcément la
réponse positive à cette demande là de
façon globale euh lorsqu'on parle de de
de lutter contre toute forme de
terrorisme et toute toute forme de
violence de violence quelle qu'elle soit
on voit qu'il est important au travers
les débats qu'on a eu pendant la lopmie
le fait de dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
que nos nos nos policiers nos gendarmes
puissent être au quotidien auprès de nos
concitoyens et pas forcément un souci
même dans la vie du quotidien on parlait
de remettre en place euh les forces dans
dans les quartiers dans les cités euh
pour participer à la vie de ces hommes
et des femmes euh au quotidien pour le
montrer qu'ils ne sont pas là que qu il
y a un problème lors lorsqu'il y a
lorsque la vie paisible euh puisse se
passer dans dans chaque endroit du
territoire français vous n AZ vous nous
avez doné fa de N recevoir mais je peux
vous garantir que la prévention
justement de tout de toutes ces dérives
de la société passe par là on doit
pouvoir reconnecter les hommes et les
femmes entre elles aut travers de nos
policiers de gendarmes qui nous
représent au quotidien et ce n'est pas
la politique qui est dépyé aujourd'hui
le fait de renforcer les gardes mobiles
n'est pas forcément la réponse idine à
nos réalité par rapport au mots max de
notre société j'en finirai en vous
disant j'espère que les débats à venir
nous permettront effectivement
directifir et de modifier la politique
quant à la sécurité sur no territoire je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
Président on va suspendre pour que vous
puissiez aller voter monsieur Paul
mollac pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outreem et territoire 4
minutes pour vous merci monsieur le
président donc monsieur le ministre des
crédits pour la sécurité qui sont en
augmentation je pense que c'est notable
votre on ne peut que souscrire à ce que
votre sécurité du quotidien parce que
c'est celle qui touche directement les
français pour l'avoir un petit peu vu en
particulier dans les violences
intrafamiliales je trouve que et les
violences sexistes je trouve que la
formation des personnels a beaucoup
augmenté et c'est la prise en charge est
quand même bien meilleure que ce qu'on
pouvait voir il y a une dizaine d'années
par exemple alors l'important c'est
évidemment le maillage territorial et je
pense évidemment au milieu rural parce
que il y a un certain nombre de
problèmes dans les milieux ruraux les
cambriolages mais aussi le fait que
certains viennent se mettre au vert
pendant un certain temps chez nous en
pensant être tranquille et en fait
peuvent commettre pas trop des méfaits
mais quelquefois servir de recessel
quelquefois ensuite repartir dans leur
travers et c'est bien de les identifier
parce qu'effectivement ça permet de
démanteler en fait des
filières alors j'avais une question en
particulier à propos des Jos et des
festivals parce que quit des forces de
l'ordre est-ce que les forces de l'ordre
par exemple qui sont dans certaines
régions vont être sollicité pour aller à
Paris ou
pas sur les grands festivals il y a eu à
peu près si vous voulez une concertation
qui fait que certains ont décalé leur le
début du Fes
soit sur le mois de juillet soit un
petit peu plus tard au mois d'août par
contre il reste un certain nombre de
festival intermédiaires dont certains
ont besoin de force de sécurité je pense
en particulier un chez moi qui est la
Madonne des motards bah évidemment les
motards sont encadrés par des motards de
la gendarmerie nationale et ça tombe
évidemment si c'est la Madonne ça tombe
le 15 août par exemple donc quid parce
que en ce moment ces festivals là sont
en train de si vous VZ voulaz de signer
des engagements pour
les tout simplement les groupes de
musique donc ils ont besoin de savoir si
ils ont l'autorisation de faire ou pas
j'ai interrogé le préfet de mon
département je pense qu'il a dû vous
interroger aussi parce qu'il m' toujours
pas donner la réponse et je pense que
peut-être que les derniers arbitrages ne
sont pas faits mais en particulier c'est
sur ces petits ou moyens festival on a
besoin d'avoir une ligne de conduite qui
sera claire
et sur l'expérimentation avec les JO
toujours on a l'expérimentation d'une
certaine intelligence artificielle pas
avec les caméras je moi savoir où est-ce
qu'on en est est-ce qu'on a choisi une
technologie quel coût ça va avoir et
queles sont les entreprises
éventuellement retenues je vous
remercie merci et Madame Ménard pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre les moyens alloués
à la sécurité doivent être augmentés et
c'est ce que vous faites dans votre
budget 2024 pour autant ce n'est
malheureusement pas toujours suffisant
pas suffisant s'agissant des moyens
alloués au renseignement plus que jamais
indispensable pour lutter contre les
atteintes à la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et des institutions et
prévenir les troubles à l'ordre public
la France n'a pas les moyens de
surveiller les personnes susceptibles de
mettre en danger notre sécurité en tout
cas pas toutes le triste attentat contre
le professeur Dominique Bernard l'a
encore prouvé la semaine dernière et en
l'absence de crédit suffisant je vous
suggère une mesure qui ne coûtera rien
mais qui pourrait être très efficace euh
est-ce que vous pouvez vous engager
monsieur le ministre à abroger la
circulaire Vals qui est source de bien
des mesures qui nous empêchent
d'expulser les étrangers potentiellement
auteur de trouble à l'ordre public je
change de sujet et je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur les conditions de
vie de nos gendarmes qui pour certains
vivent dans des logements qui présentent
un état de véuseté plus qu'alarmant et
pour résoudre ce problème la gendarmerie
de Bézier notamment a été obligé
d'autoriser une prise à bail en secteur
civil ce qui entraîne un surcû pour
l'institut tution et donc ma question
est simple quel programme allez-vous
mettre en place monsieur le ministre
pour y remédier et enfin dernier point
j'en aurais beaucoup d'autres vous vous
en doutez mais je vais essayer d'aller
vite dernier point la montée en
puissance des violences en France tout
le monde se souvient des émeutes de
l'été dernier et cette montée des
violences nécessite pour les combattre
des effectifs supplémentaires c'est
prévu dans votre budget néanmoins la
cour des compte nous alerte sur la crise
de vocation qui frappe nos forces de
l'ordre ainsi que sur les vagues de
démission qui frappe nos institutions le
nombre de départ de la police et de la
gendarmerie en 2022 est en hausse par
rapport à 20221 qui manquait qui
marquait pourtant un record et face à ce
constat quels moyen comptez-vous engager
pour rendre nos forces de l'ordre plus
attractives monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie alors monsieur le ministre vous
avez la réponse pour cette première
série de questions merci monsieur le
Président beaucoup de de questions je
propose de répondre sur les questions
d'actualité à la fin peut-être pour
répondre au crédit budgétaire en tout
façon un petit peu
euh passant peut-être par la la fin vers
le début pour dire à Madame Ménard que
la question de la dette immobilière qu'
le ministère de l'intérieur elle est
très importante il y a deux grandes
detettes au ministère d' l'intérieur une
dette numérique j'ai essayé de vous en
parler tout à l'heure dans mon prop
introductif qu'on résout ou qu'on
résorbe et puis la dette immobilière qui
qui pass simplement les locaux des des
gendarmes et et leur habitation on peut
être loc des policiers lo des
préfectures aussi pourquoi parce que
pendant très longtemps le ministère de
l'Intérieur a eu une augmentation très
importante de ce qu'on appelle son T2
son personnel et des crédits qui étaient
h de notamment d'immobilier qui ne
suivaient pas soit les augmentations de
personnel soit les changements
évidemment de vie de nos concitoyens et
et parfois le travail très important qui
a été fait a été un travail de je fais
payer aux collectivités local si je
pense aux
gendarmes les les les constructions je
paye des loyers mais en fait évidemment
au début ça paraît moins intéressant que
d'être propriétaire mais à la fin
surtout quand il s'agit de petite
communes et ben les loyers n'augmentant
pas forcément aux mesures qu'il faudrait
pour pouvoir faire les travaux de
rénovation notamment des logements pour
les militaires de la gendarmerie on en
est à difficulté extrêmement forte je ne
parle pas des cathédrales que sont les
grandes casernes si on prendemple
exemple de satori par exemple qui pose
des problèmes évidemment très importants
c'est pour ça qu'on est a mis à la fois
beaucoup de moyens supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire les moyens que vous avez
voté dans la lopmie grosso modo 300 plus
de 300 millions mais ça ne suffira pas
non plus et donc nous imaginons deux
modes totalement différents et j'en ai
parlé devant votre commission lors de
l'alopmie de de gestion même si ce n'est
pas le domaine public ce n'est pas moi
qui le gère directement mais vous savez
qu'il y a un ministre du domaine public
qui est le ministre en charge des
comptes publics mais on y travaille
beaucoup le premier c'est une foncière
et une foncière qui partagerait notre
action avec le privé tout en étant
majoritaire évidemment ne serce que pour
faire des travaux de transition
énergétique et où les R innovation plus
lourde donc la question de de comment on
gère l'immobilier public de l'État et
notamment des brigades de gendarmerie
des commissariats de police j' profite
pour répondre à madameard en même temps
c'est évidemment une question d'abord de
de de fonctionnement parce que l'État ne
sait pas toujours très bien gérer son
domaine public est très grand et
çaagissant du ministère l'intérieur qui
est partout sur le territoire national
et avec les autres maires international
surtout dans des conditions très
différents évidemment d'invention il y a
la petite brigade de campagne jusqu'à la
grande préfecture donc évidemment c'est
une difficulté extrêmement en for de
gestion donc il d'abord il la question
de la foncière et puis il y a une
question très importante qui est que
sont les partenariats public privés et
donc nous pensons nous que la
construction par d'une partie des 239
brigades mais aussi la reconstruction
des casernes plus importantes peuvent se
faire en massifiant les appels d'offre
et donc en divisant la France en
plusieurs régions qui permettrait de
faire jouer la concurrence et de faire
nêtre un partenarat public privé pour
lequel nous restons propriétairees à la
fin puisque je pense que le défaut qui
qu'on eu les mises en l'intérieur
d'ailleurs précédemment c'était souvent
de déléguer aux collectivités locales de
la construction de payer des loyers et
et d'avoir ces difficultés de dette
immobilière bien évidemment donc oui
vous avez parfaitement raison on résout
la dette immobilière peu à peu on a 750
brigades de gendarmerie auou
commissariat de police depuis que je
suis mis àintérieur rénové ou
reconstruit mais il y a beaucoup de
travail et et bien sûr ça va être le cas
sans doute dans votre dans votre
département ou comme dans celui de
Madame de Madame broc
euh évoquer la la question des des des
personnels puisque ça a été dit par
plusieurs personnes notamment dans la
police nationale moi je voudrais
m'inscrire en faux et j'ai eu l'occasion
dans ma réponse à la Cour des comptes de
le dire on est à 0,5 % en moins de
sous-consommation de crédit personnel en
2022 puisque la Cour des comptes évoquit
la question notamment de 2022 et la
question des démission bien sûr toujours
est intéressante à regarder pour voir la
dynamique qui peut y avoir dans dans une
administration
elle est à relativiser très largement
dans la gendarmerie comme dans la police
puisque les deux forces sont concernées
notamment parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
démissions de gardien de la paix pour
devenir officier pour la gendarmerie
pour la police nationale pardon ou pour
devenir officier pour les gendarmes et
les sousof et donc évidemment quand on
fait beaucoup de promotions à terne
parce que la police nationale par
exemple c'est 50 % de gardiens de la
paix qui deviennent officier au
commissaire 50 % et donc vous
démissionnez formellement pour pouvoir
rentrer dans le statut d'officier
commissaire donc il faut il faut
évidemment relativiser les chiffres
donnés par par la Cour c'est ma réponse
d'ailleurs qui est indexé évidemment au
rapport de la cour des compte et en ce
qui concerne là je suis encore un peu
plus circonspect évidemment sur
l'attractivité d'abord en 2023 ça
vérifie pas du tout les chiffres de 2022
l'année 2022 posait une question un peu
particulière qui était quand même celle
du taux de chômage et c'est vrai dans
toute la fonction publique quand le taux
de chômage est bas la fonction publique
est de moins en moins une valeur refuge
il y a donc moins moins de possibilités
d'intérêt pour la fonction publique
c'est vrai au ministère de l'intérieur
c'est vrai au ministère des armées vous
avez remarqué d'ailleurs que une
communication a été faite pour dire
qu'ils ont du mal à recruter alors que
c'est sans doute un grand ministère de
recrutement et c'est vrai évidemment
d'autres ministères al ça veut pas dire
que les missions sont pas difficiles ça
veut pas dire comme on l'a très bien dit
tout à l'heure la desmitaire suffit
madame rol a raison ça ça suffit ça
suffit pas et donc il y a le sens de la
mission il y a il y a la formation il y
a l'attractivité après là où je suis
moins en accord avec l'intervention à la
fois des des veres et de de Madame la la
représentante de la France insoumise
c'est quand on évoque notamment sur les
sur les suicides bah je pense que si on
avait des mots plus positifs sur la
police nationale peut-être que ce sera
un peu mieux pour qu'ils puissent se
sentir bien dans leur métier les
manifestations on dit suicidez-vous
c'est pas super on dit que la police tue
c'est c'est pas super les attaques de
Monsieur Mélenchon contre la police
nationale c'est pas super donc
évidemment ça peut aider évidemment à
trouver de l'intérêt dans votre dans
votre métier voilà sur le le la la
l'attractivité de la la la la
l'administration territoriale je sais
pas vous avez vu madame regol que les
les crédits baissés il au contraire ils
ont ils ont augmenté
2,3 milliards à 2,6 milliards 2020-224
c'est 232 qui va en temps plein 2024 il
y a jamais eu d'augmentation aussi
importante dans l'administration
territoriale donc je je je suis désolé
mais je vois pas où vous voyez baisses
de crédit pour l'administration
territoriale dans les préfectures ils
augmentent et ils augmentent non
seulement en montant mais ils augmentent
en en personnel sur euh
la question de de la Guyane qui évoqué
par Monsieur le Député enfin de manière
générale évidemment sur les les autres
mes moi je j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
mon propos introductif les les
augmentations d'effectifs pérennes plus
de 30 % de policiers en outrem et de
gendarmes en outrem sans lesr de
gendarmerie mobile et notamment en
Guyane vous avez posé une question très
très importante celle de harpi bien sûr
il faut qu'on augmente sans doute la
posture et qu'on changetroductif la
façon dont on fait harpi en en Guyane
parce que d'ailleurs il compris
d'ailleurs ceux qui viennent faire leur
paillage illégal et qui pollue la terre
de guyan bien évidemment et qui qui la
pille et qui parfois font des règlements
de compte vous le savez bien s'adapte et
donc on le partage vous le savez avec
nos amis militaires donc c'est un
travail en commun le président de la
République a demandé une nouvelle
opération harpi imaginé donc on aura
l'occasion d' d'y d'en reparler ensemble
et vous avez parfaitement raison sans
doute que le travail que font les
escadrons de gendarmerie à l'exception
de ceux qui tiennent l'aéroport de
Guyane et à l'exception aussi de ceux
qui font parfois du mtien d'ord public
pourra être davantage mis en avant sur
la question harpi que sur d'autres
questions que vous évoquez et pour ter
la la terre des des des Guyanais je
partage tout à fait votre votre opinion
sur ce point vous m'ave demandz
rendez-vous je recevrai bien volontiers
pour pour en parler et il y a les 21
escadrons de de gendarmerie qui sont
puisqueil n'y a que la gendarmerie qui
fait l'outr-em les 21 escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile qui sont mobilisés
pour l'ensemble de notre mère resteront
il compris pendant les Jeux Olympiques
qui sont même renforcés en Polynésie
française pendant le le le cas des des
vous savez de la la la la preuve de de
surf sur les dépenses de formation là
aussi j'ai j'ai un peu de mal à à
comprendre les les démonstrations fa
qu'on on reparle monsieur le député euh
euh de du 0 ETP puisque évident ce n'est
pas le le cas euh mais les crédits de
formation en personnel ne ne ne ne
baisse pas je sais pas où vous avez vu
ça en 2022 on est à 23 millions 2023 29
millions donc on est à 30 millions pour
l'année prochaine 4500 équivalent temps
plein et 72 pour répondre à votre
question à ma connaissance de gens
recrutés créés en plus des policiers qui
basculent dans la formation 72
équivalent templ en 2023 euh donc on
aura l'occasion voilà je peut-être que
document budgétaire soit il y a une
coquille dedans soit on aura l'occasion
de de les relire ensemble le dispositif
fr alerte est efficient sur l'ensemble
du territoire national à à l'exception
de la réunion de mayottes et des
Antilles qui et ce sera évidemment
augmenté c'est un dispositif qui est
extrêmement efficace et nous aurons donc
l'occasion sans doute d'en d'en reparler
monsieur le député sur la question du
FIPD de la prévention de la délinquance
là aussi madame regol je partage pas
votre lecture des chiffres puisqu'ils
augmentent vous vous disiez que que ca
baissé euh donc 80 millions d'euros tout
tout tout prélèvement euh concernant
pour les FIPD hein euh 80000 € 800
millions d'euros 2022 84 millions
d'euros 2023 87 millions en 2024 94
millions 2025 et ce n'est pas la caméas
de vidéoprection qui prennent tout
puisque c'est 22 millions d'euros en
2023 pour les caméras et 25 millions
d'euros en 2024 donc voilà une
augmentation générale des crédit de
prévention la délinquance dont les
caméras mais pas simplement les les
caméras les canaderses seront livrés je
le dir ici au 2000 début 2026 pour les
premières livraisons vous savez que nous
avons à la fois une difficulté de
construction de de de d'usin pour
construire les les sites mais aussi euh
de pouvoir nous battre pour pouvoir
récupérer des livraisons de canadaer à
temps puisque nos amis canadiens ont
eux-même connu des feux très importants
et ont voulu prioriser les chaînes de
montage mais ce sera évidemment
l'occasion euh de concrétiser les
annonces du président de de la
République sur la question des violences
INRA familiales la formation des
policiers aujourd'hui l'intégralité 100
% des policiers des gendarmes qui
sortent d'écolees de police sont formés
aux violenceces enrein familiales on en
est à 80 % pour l'ensemble des policiers
des gendarmes qui sont en contact avec
le public il y a évidemment toujours des
améliorations à faire je rappelle quand
même que sur 100 féminicides 30 sont
connus euh des forces de l'ordre parce
que il y a eu une enquête parce qu'il y
a eu une plainte parce qu'il y a eu
quelqu'un qui est venu les voir et 70 ne
sont pas connus en aucun cas des forces
de l'ORD donc bien sûr on peut largement
améliorer encore le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes on le fait
aussi pour des raisons qui tiennent
au contact parfois avec la police ou la
gendarmerie donc nous multiplions les
plaintes à domicile la vis plainte qu'on
va
généraliser par exemple mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de travail à faire avec
tout la communauté de ceux qui peuvent
dénoncer des vices intrafamiliales et je
l'occasion de m'exprimer d'ailleurs y
compris le monde médical qui souvent est
le premier à le constater nous nous
aurons donc l'occasion sans doute d'y
revenir mais je partage pas évidemment
l'opinion sur l'accueil il y a beaucoup
d'efforts encore à faire mais je crois
que chacun constate l'énorme effort qu'a
eu la police et la gendarmerie dans
l'accueil des violences intra familiales
sur les les logements des gendarmes
répondre à Madame la Députée que nous
avons l'occasion d'augmenter les crédits
de paiement encore cette année mais je
pense qu'elle en a vu même le bénéfice
dans sa
circonscription ce qui est sûr comme
j'ai dit à Madame Ménard c'est que il y
a une dette num une dette immobilière
très importante et qu'il faut qu'on
change de braquet pour pouvoir
évidemment être au rendez-vous de
l'ensemble de la demande des gendarmes
et de leur famille qui qui vivent
évidemment dans des conditions souvent
difficiles alors je sais pas où madame
regol a vu qu'il y avait 6000 OPJ
seulement au contact avec le public
madame Martin pardon excusez-moi 6000
contact avec le avec le avec le public
puisque nous avons 17000 OPJ dans la
police il y en a que 4500 à la dnpj donc
je pense que vous vous trompez de
chiffres c'est le triple madame madame
Martin ça veut pas dire qu'il manque pas
non non je je vois très bien non si
vousi pas pas interrompu je vous ai je
vous ai je vous ai écouté donc voilà il
y a il y a un triple d'OPJ c'est quand
même pas simple triple c'est pas voilà
mais vous avez réussi en même temps dans
la lopmie voter contre le fait qu'on
formait dès la dès l'école de police les
les OPJ et puis en même temps me
réclamer des OPJ donc vous nêtes pas une
contradiction contradiction près
malheureusement mais oui alors je vous
permets pas Madame regol ouais non
madame madame Martin madame martinapp
oui madame Martin mesdames messieurs les
députés vous allez écouter monsieur le
ministre tout se passa bien jusqu'à
présent il y a pas de raison que ça
dérape alors je sais qu' a l'habitude
d'insulte dans votre parti mais c'est
pas la peine de progresser dans de ce
point et on continue l'audition du
ministre voilà merci min la parole et
merci de ne pas m'insulter vous per non
mais c'est pas parce que des problème
entre la nu en ce moment qu'il faut vous
passer votre ner sur membre du
gouvernement je propose je vous propose
que votre je propose je propose queos
vos difficulté politique ne ne se
reflète pas dans les commissions
parlementaires on continue on
continue ça suffit ça suffit on continue
maintenant ça suffit madame Martin vous
n'avez plus la parole je crois que
cracher sur venin c'est ce qu'a fait
madame obono ce matin à la tête de tous
les Français euh donc vous pr mieux vous
présenter vos excuses plutôt que votre
énervement donc ceux qui est sûr c'est
que nous avons pas les mêmes chiffres
d'OPJ puis comme vous avez pas vraiment
voulu rentrer dans une discussion
d'écoute et de et de respect je vais
donc m'en arrêter là sur la question que
posait tout à l'heure monsieur le
rapporteur sur les réservistes nous
sommes à 6000 322 policiers nationaux
qui ont sont rentrés dans la réserve
opérationnelle depuis le 1er septembre
ce qui est donc un grand succès on peut
les rencontrer évidemment toutes et tous
dans les dans les préfectures qui se
décomposent en 4027 policiers retraités
qui désormais gardent leur qualité d'epj
grâce à votre action 397 anciens
policiers adjoints et 1898 personnes de
la société civile c'est donc une grande
efficacité me semble-t-il de de notre
travail collectif et notamment de la
réserve opérationnelle que vous avez
créé ce modèle de la gendarmerie en ce
qui concerne mais je pense que c'est
important le travail que fait la
sécurité civile pour répondre à Monsieur
le le rapporteur et aux autres
parlementaires qui sont intéressés à la
question de la sécurité civile il y a
évidemment une question et vous avez
raison c'est surtout en partie 2 qu'on
va il arver c'estàd sur le financement
il a à se reposer la question des
ressources de la TSCA mais aussi la
façon dont les départements participent
puisqueune partie de partie de la
TSCA une partie de la TSCA est versée
direct
au au au département qui laavers au 10
et il y a des moments les départements
jouent le jeu renversement à 100 % il y
en a d'autres d'ailleurs qui donnent
plus que ce qui est prévu et puis y en a
qui donnent moins et puis il y a pas
tous les mêmes problèmes dans tous les
départements puisque évidemment il y a
parfois des des carence il y a parfois
des feux de forêt ce qui est pas le cas
tous les départements il y a donc une
solidarité sans doute à voir entre les
départements est-ce que la TSA est une
bonne taxe faut-il en prévoir d'autres
faut-il les transférer autrement on en
tout cas on est tout à fait prêt pour
pour en discuter je vrais quand même
souligner que l'État don c'est pas la
compétence verse 1 milliard sur les 4
milliards des fonctionnement des 10
alors que ce ne s'agit pas de compétence
stctocensu de l'État pour une compétence
qui a été totalement décentralisé sur la
question de des ingénieurs qui doivent
rejoindre la police technique et
scientifique et ù le monde du du cyber
c'est à peu près la même question à la
fois je pense qu'il faut jouer sur la
rémunération ça a été très bien dit nous
sommes en train de négocier avec Bery un
travail interministériel pour prévoir
une augmentation de 20 % tous les 3 ans
de la rémunération des personnes qui
viendrait de l'extérieur pour rendre
service à la nation ce que son le modèle
d'ailleurs que ce que nous faisons la
DGSI qui est un modèle qui permet
d'accueillir des contractuels notamment
des informaticiens ou des spécialistes
en intelligence artificielle pour
pouvoir nous aider je pense que le sens
de la mission parfois compte plus aussi
qu' la rémunération pour plein de
raisons il faut qu'on les accompagne
notamment dans le casre de de des
incompatibilités professionnelles de la
suite parce que passer quelques années à
faire des grands projets numériques au
ministère de l'intérieur ça permet
évidemment d'enrichir son son CV il faut
pas le il faut pas le le le rejeté et
puis on a évidemment un sujet de modèle
et donc Clement l'agence du numérique
que nous avons créé peut-être que la
police technique et scientifique doit
s'en inspirer n permet de libérer d'
certain nombre de contraintes de la djfp
donc on aura l'occasion d' d'en reparler
en tout cas je partage tout à fait les
attendus les conclusion de votre de
votre rapport euh sur la question
évidemment des heures supplémentaires
pour le casadre des des Jeux Olympiques
pour l'instant nous av'avons pas de
discussion avec les les syndicats
notamment de police sur sur ce point
mais on s'est engagé en interministériel
aprè sera annoncé une prime qui
concernerait l'ensemble des policiers
des gendarmes de manière générale les
agents du ministère de l'Intérieur et
les agents des autres ministères
particulèrement mobilisés euh on est
tout à fait prêt à regarder avec Bercy
évidemment si ces heures supplémentaires
si les f pass notamment les tranches de
barem sur le revenu puissent être
défiscalisé je connais trop le
fonctionnement de Bery pour pas
m'engager devant vous mais comme je sais
que Bery est toujours à l'écoute et
toujours généreux et notamment il a été
avec le budget du ministère de
l'intérieur mais oui mais pour pour ça
il faut avoir servi aber pour savoir
comment ça fonctionne et donc c'est pour
ça que vous avez des des crédits
supplémentaires dans ce ministère je je
je m'engage évidemment à regarder ça
parce qu'il feront un effort très
particulier les policiers gendarmes
refuseront évidemment leur jour de congé
pendant cet été ce qui me permet dire à
Monsieur mollac que on va trouver sans
doute une solution pour que euh le
festival
motard Madonne des motards puisse
bénissent les motos oui oui euh
spécialiste monsieur le député euh donc
puisse puisse se tenir dans des
conditions évidemment comme tous les
autres autre festival bien sûr sur la
question des des permis Monsieur R
monsieur RIBEROT sur le le point en
moins que nous allons annulé nous avons
transmis au Conseil d'État le texte qui
était conforme à mon engagement le 10
octobre dernier et donc au 1er janvier
2024 les conducteurs ne se verront plus
retirer leurs petits points pour des
petits excès de vitesse évidemment ils
pourront toujours ils devront toujours
payer l'amende hein il s'agit pas de de
dépénaliser le le point pour prendre une
expression à la mode mais de d'être dans
le bon sens vous avez parfaitement
raison et donc c'est une promesse
promesse tenue sur l'intelligence
artificiell et les caméras de vidéo
protection la notification a été faite
fin novembre des marchés enfin sera
faite fin novembre des marchés pardon et
donc pour Noël nous aurons notifié
l'intégralité des marchés ce qui nous
permettra évidemment de pouvoir répondre
à votre question sur l'utilisation des
moyens que vous avez voté dans la loi
qui est la loi
euh Jo au sens très large du terme de
Madame oua Castera et que j'ai porté
évidemment alors peut-être sur un un
point particulier qui touche
l'immigration même si c'est pas le sujet
des crédits d'aujourd'hui je je joue
bien volontiers au jeu de la réponse au
commissaire au loi et d'ailleurs moi
jeux redire le président m'a informé de
sa décision je le remercie parce que ça
évite effectivement de venir plusieurs
fois de notre commission ce qui est
toujours une joie sans cesse renouvelé
mais mais qui évidemment nous permet
peut-être de mutualiser et c'est pour ça
que j'y réponds bien volontiers je n'ai
jamais refusé de répondre à aucune
question du par Parlement bon d'ailleurs
je constate cet après-midi que vous
m'avez pas posé de question à part le
président Houet j'ai constaté j'ai
constaté j'ai constaté que le
rassemblement national ou les LR ne
m'ont pas posé de questions
personnellement alors je je je je je
sais pas peut-être que vous attendiez la
commission mais ça pas été l'occasion de
le faire peut-être que vous attendiez à
la réponse que je vais vous formuler
c'est une réponse qui évidemment malgré
le drame peut vous mettre dans
l'embarras alors maintenant vous m'avez
demandé Mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires notamment du du RN et du
DLR de comment ça comment la faire
est-il ble bon ben moi je trouve que
évidemment dans le drame qui touche aras
qui touche cette famille de professeurs
et ceux qui sont blessés d'abord je
vrais saluer le courage des enseignants
du personnel administratif du lycée qui
ont effectivement empêché sans doute le
terroriste islamiste de faire davantage
de dégâts de morts je remercie aussi la
police nationale qui en moins de 4
minutes est intervenue très
courageusement euh s'est mis en contact
avec le terroristebiste qui a quelques
mètres d'entre eux crié avec un couteau
et alors qu'il avait déjà tué dans une
scène de sang affreuse et ils n'ont pas
utilisé leur arme administrative mais
ils ont utilisé le Taser tiens c'est
bizarre parce qu'on a voulu parfois
l'interdire le Taser c'est un effectif
de voie publique et pour que cette
personne puisse être neutralisée sans
jamais effectivement causer la mort je
pense qu'on peut saluer les policiers
d'aras également et je remercie le
président de la République d'avoir
décidé de les décorer de d'ordre
nationaux pour pour leur patrouille de
de voix publique courageuse alors une
fois que j'ai dit ça
Yakub mogutchov et Madame kabille
oxanova son épouse sont arrivés monsieur
le député Bouar avec qu enfants le 10
mars
2008 une de leurs filles est née en
France le 28 avril 2013 mais leurs
quatre enfants précédents étaient déjà
nés en Russie il se trouve que le père
était déjà signalé pour une pratique
extrêmement radicale de l'islam ils ont
demandé leur admission de séjour au
titre de l'asile 27 mars 2008 l'OFPRA a
rejeté leur demande d'asile le 16
décembre 2008 la CNDA la cour d'appel a
rejeté le recours le 13 janvier 2010
après un nouveau examen de l'OFPRA
déposé le 16 février 2010 l'OFPRA a de
nouveau rejeté le 2 mars 2010 ils ont
alors fait l'objet d'un refus de séjour
un eqtf le 11 mai 2010 le Tribunal
administratif de Rennes a rejeté le
recours parce qu'ils ont fait un recours
le 23 septembre 2010 confirmé par la
cour d'appel de Nantes le 14 avril 2011
vous aurez donc constaté monsieur le
député que alors que ce sont des
personnes qui je crois n'étaient pas mou
à l'époque en responsabilité puisqu'il
s'agissait du du quinquena auquel
particip la la droite républicaine de
2008 à 2011 3 ans se sont passés 3 ans
où le gouvernement ne pouvait pas
appliquer les reconduites aux frontières
puisquil y avait des recours alors vous
me posez la question de savoir vous
disiez enfin vous posez pas la question
vous disiez comme Monsieur MX tout à
l'heure votre loi changerait rien bien
au contraire puisque ce avec la nouvelle
loi nous pourra on entendra plus 3 ans
puisque le principe c'est d'après
notamment la réforme de la CNDA si elle
est votée tel qu'elle proposée par le
gouvernement nous aurions jugé tout cela
en moins de 7 mois mais là il y a eu par
la multiplicité des recours recours
asile recours administratif 3 ans et je
n'en veux pas évidemment à ce
gouvernement pendant 3 ans les personnes
n'étaient pas expulsables alors à partir
euh du 14 avril 2011 ils étaient
expulsables là le qtf n'a pas été
exécuté ce qui montre bien d'ailleurs
que la volonté de pas exécuter les eqtf
c'est pas un truc propre au ministre de
l'intérieur du président de la
République c'est vrai depuis très
longtemps depuis que les eqtf existent
puisque 20 % c'est le tau maximum qui a
été réussi dans l'exécution des eqtf en
France en 2019 c'était bien moins le cas
déjà en 2011 et c'est aussi vrai que la
France a le taux un des taux les plus
importants de reconduite à la frontière
maisme si on a des des des des mesures
différentes selon selon les états entre
2011 et 2013 il y a donc eu euh deux
eqtf l'un du gouvernement de Monsieur
Fillon l'autre du gouvernement de
Monsieur héros euh qui ont été notifiés
sans pouvoir être exécutés ils ont
sollicité l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour c'est-à-dire une régularisation
au nom de la circulaire Vals hein la es
qui lui a été euh manifestement refusé
et le 23 juillet 2013 ils étaient euh
assignés à résidence puis le 11 octobre
2013 et le 4 décembre 2014 pour 90 jours
en Bretagne le Consolat de le consulat
de Russie a saisi le 28 novembre 2013
par le ministère des Affaires étrangères
a attribué les laisser passer consulaire
donc là voilà un cas où euh la Russie
donnait s'est laissé passer consulaire
le 13 février 2014
le 18 février 2014 à 6h du matin la
gendarmerie a notifié le placement en
rétention et les a transporté de
l'aéroport de Rennes au centre de
rétention administrative du Ménil
Hamelot qui est en île-de-fance pour un
départ de roissi le 18 février
c'est-à-dire quelques heures après leur
leur transfert de la Bretagne à
l'île-de-fance et puis et puis au moment
de rentrer dans l'avion à quelques
minutes près sur instruction du cabinet
ministérial de ministreintérieur de
l'époque on a remis en liberté la
famille évoquée et on a transféré cette
famille du coup dans le Pas de calé donc
pour parler de sujet qui explique savoir
comment les gens sont arrivés là sont
arrivés là sous un premier gouvernement
de droite de 2008 à 2011 ils n'ont pas
pu être expulsés malgré les démarches
fait par le ministère de l'Intérieur de
l'époque par la longévité des recours
donc première réponse le projet de loi
répond tout à fait à cette problématique
en divisant par trois les procédures dur
de recours passant de 12 à 4 pour la
pour la bonne simple raison que le Roget
le le la demande d'asile refusé valer au
qtf on aurait gagné beaucoup de temps à
l'époque le qtf n'a pas été exécuté pour
des raisons sans doute difficiles à
exécuter c'est pas moi qui vais en faire
le reproche puis lorsque la famille
souhaitait de nouveau être régularisée
au nom de la circulaire de Monsieur Vals
qui a été refusé à l'époque par le
gouvernement de Monsieur HRO elle a donc
failli être expulsé et libéré parce que
tout le monde l'a vu il y a eu des
pressions politicoassociatives pour
libérer cette ces personnes comme il en
existe souvent et quand parfois parfois
je dis sans provocation il arrive que
les parlementaires s'en fassent le
relais quel que soit leur bord politique
par ailleurs qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qui s non je pense que c'est
assez partagé il arrive même d'ailleurs
que des gens de votre groupe m'éccrive
monsieur le député du rassemblement
national et si vous voulez on échange
quand vous voulez les
informations ne prenez pas ne ne prenez
pas à Paris monsieur le député parce que
vous risquez de le perdre et ce serait
malencontreux bon donc la vérité la
vérité non parce qu'on a tous On connait
tous une nounou qu'il faut absolument
régulariser voyez ce que je veux dire
elle elle est bien voilà ça ce qu'on me
dit voilà bon donc je le dis parce que
ça peut arriver et c'est pas grave et
c'est très bien je suis le premier à
dire que quand des gens sont très bien
il faut pas avoirir les accueillir je
ferme la parenthèse qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ensuite peut-être sous les
quinquen du président de la République
la famille est donc dans l'illégalité je
parle des du papa de la maman des
enfants qui vont commencer à devenir
majeurs au fur à mesure que les années
passent mais ils sont tous arrivés avant
l'âge de 13 ans sur le territoire
national lorsque nous savons que le père
est en effet suivi pour radicalisation
et alors que nous savons que cette
personne n'a pas eu l'asile le ministre
l'Intérieur de l'époque il s'agissait de
Gérard Colom a fait mettre la le père
avec un eqtf qui CCI à exécuter l'a
renvoyé dans son pays d'origine
aujourd'hui ce père est d'après notre
nos informations en geéorgie et donc ce
père fiches a été expulsé du territoire
national euh par le ministre Gérard conb
le frère le frère le plus important le
le au sens le plus grand de la fratterie
a été mis en prison pour un article 40
fait par la DGSI parce que nous savions
qu'il était en effet radicalisé fich s
il a été mis en prison sur demande du
ministre de l'intérieur après validation
évidemment du magistrat puis en prison a
connu une peine plus grande parce qu'il
aurait participé euh en tout cas il
aurait imaginé la participation euh à
l'attentat qui auraitvisait le pays de
l'Élysée si celui-ci avait réussi donc
le père expulsé le frère fichs pas
expulsé mais en prison le ministère de
l'Intérieur ce président de la
République je crois a fait son travail
le frère celui qui est l'auteur
terroriste de l'attentat d'aras à l'âge
de 18 ans recommence une démarche
puisqu'il redemande l'asile non pas
parce que ses parents l'ont pas eu mais
une fois qu'il est majeur il répond
instittu personnel de sa propre vie
administrative et demande l'asile et on
est reparti on a redemandé l'asile à
l'OFPRA et après comme ça a été refusé
on a redemandé l'asile à la cndda qui en
août 2022 a dit non en mars 2022
monsieur Poutine envahi l'Ukraine les
relations diplomatiques avec la France
sont suspendues alors que nous
reprenions en effet les expulsions mais
ça n'aurait rien changé dans le cas
précis de l'auteur terroriste puisque
cet auteur terroriste ne l''était pas à
l'époque il n'a aucun casier judiciaire
il est sur un fichier de renseignement
et notamment suiv par DGSI depuis
juillet 2023 et cela fait ce cela
faisait seulement à peu près 2 mois 2
mois et demi qu'il était sous écoute
téléphonique et sous géoquisation les
dizaines d'heures d'écoute téléphoniqu
n'ont rien donné et aucun signe
malheureusement alors qu'il y avait
doute on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
si vous le souhaitez aucun signe ne
permettait d'accrocher la personne au
nom de violence terroriste potentielle
qui aurait permis d'utiliser en effet ce
qu'a évoqué Madame Le Pen dans
l'hémicycle mais qui ne correspond en
rien à la réité des faits les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation n'étaient pas
concernés par cette personne et ça peut
arriver dans d'autres est pas là le seul
moyen que nous avions de l'expulser
c'était de l'attraper si je veux dire au
nom de l'ordre public du désordre public
mais aujourd'hui monsieur le député
depuis les lois qui ont mené à la fin de
la fin de la double peine il y a
proprement au droit français c'est pas
dans la Constitution c'est pas dans la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme c'est dans la loi française que
nous fabriquons que vous fabriquez il y
a dans la loi française des réserves
d'entre publique qui fait vous le savez
bien que quelqu'un arrivé avant l'âge de
13 ans sur le territoire national qui
s'est marié avec un français qui a des
enfants sur le sol français qui est
resté depuis un certain temps sur sol
national n'est pas expulsable n'est pas
expulsable sauf intérêt fondamental de
la nation le dossier de ce monsieur ne
permettait pas de penser en aucun cas
qu'il avait attenté évidemment aux
intérêts de la nation en revanche il
avait frappé manifestement sa maman ce
qui lui avait valu une garde à vue
l'année dernière et alors que sa maman
ne n'a pas déposé plainte alors même
qu'il y a pas eu de condamnation puisque
la plainte a été classée ensite le
préfet du pas decalis Monsieur Louis
lefran à qui je rends hommage parce que
à chaque fois on dit quand ça va mal
mais moi je veux dire quand ça va bien
Leureux homme qui aujourd'hui est au
commissaire de la République en nouvelle
Conie il a écouté les instructions du
ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque
c'est-à-dire pardon d' modestie mais de
moi-même en disant toute personne
étrangère qui est mis en garde vue qui
est accusé par des services de police
gendarmerie on doit procéder à son n son
retrait tire de séjour et où son
expulsion il a donc vu un étranger qui
était irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national puisque débout et de l'asile
mais sans qtf parce que j'ai pas le
droit d'en mettre puisque il est russe
mais surtout parce que il est protégé
subsidiairement par la protection des
moins de 13 ans et donc il a consulté le
ministère de l'Intérieur et la delpag
pour dire qu'est-ce que je peux faire de
ce monsieur qui a accusé accusé de
violence intrafamiliale même pas
condamné accusé de violence
intrafamiliale et qui mériterait sans
doute de retourner dans son pays selon
votre circulaire monsieur ministre la
DLPAJ a répondu oui vous avez bien fait
de nous appeler mais non le trou double
à l'ordre public que constitue la
violence intrafamiliale c'est pas pardon
on peut regretter mais c'est pas une
attaque une attaque fondamental à
l'intérêt national la violence
intrafamiliale c'est un trouble à
l'ordre publicique tout à fait condamne
mais c'est pas la même chose qu'un acte
terroriste en préparation vous ne pouvez
pas l'expulser parce qu'il y a C cette
cette mesure et euh la mesure des moins
de 13 ans donc monsieur le député
deuxème réponse que pourraz apporter le
projet de loi ce que nous vous proposons
c'est les articles 9 10 et 13 du projet
de loi qui sont en consultation voté par
vos amis sénateurs par ailleurs ce qui
ils ont dû les trouver bon puisque la
droite sénatoriale les a voté et qui
sont sortis de la commission article 9
nous prévoyons l'expulsion immédiate ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui de
toute personne qui a été condamnée pour
10 ans ou 5 ans récidifs de prison
l'expulsion c'est pas l'éloignement
c'est je prends un arrêté ministériel
des des de d'exclusion il n'est pas
susceptible de recours sauf un en
urgence et je peux obtenir une ame ça
c'est le 9 article 10 toute personne qui
trouble l'ordre public au sens menace de
l'ordre public y compris donc les
violences int famamiliales mais ça peut
être s' prendre un policier ça peut être
trafiqué de drogue ça peut tout ce qui
ressemble à un
délit on suspendra les réserves d'ordre
publique à l'exception d'une seule
puisque nous avons signé la Convention
Européenne des droit de l'enfant et que
c'est en judiciaire qui sont les mineurs
qui commettent des actes graves pendant
qu'ils sont mineurs puisque ça relève
pas là de l'administratif ça relève du
judiciaire toutes les autres sautent
toute personne demain si le loi la loi
est votée qui trouble l'ordre public et
qui est
étrangère l'objet effectivement d'un
eqtf et d'un éloignement et puis article
13 très intéressant l'article
13 nous permet de tirer si je dire plus
large et de considérer et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a même des amendements que l'on
pourrait rajouter tous ens si on y
travaille ensemble sans jeter d'un a
thème la possibilité de faire sauter
l'intégralité des mesures de
d'éloignement en disant que il y a un
équilibre à faire entre la vie privée
familiale article 8 de la CEDH et
finalement la sécurité de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui il est écrit euh
vre vie privée et familiale et intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation demain on y
écrira vie privée familiale les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation le terrorisme
et les troubles à l'ordre public donc
pour répondre à votre question c'est
tout à fait faux de dire d'abord un que
le gouvernement et notamment les
services des étrangers de la préfecture
du pcalé mais aussi la DGSI je pourrais
revenir c'est pas votre question mais je
pourrais revenir on raté quelque chose
il y a toujours non mais je suis pas
pour vous je dis ça pour tout le monde
voilà parce que j'ai entendu monsieur
Marle tout à l'heure dans une
démonstration qui m'a paru un peu loin
du ballon si je peux me permettre
bon c'est pas une c'est pas une insulte
régle vos différents réglez vos
différents internes à votre groupe et
laisszist non mais c'est pas une insulte
c'est pas une insulte on va laisser des
républicains s'entendre entre eux et
puis on va laisser teriner le ministre
non mais c'est un sujet c'est un sujet
non moi je ve dire monsieur le député
c'est un sujet très sérieux d'une part
et je comprends tout à fait votre
question en tant que parlementaire au
gouvernement mais permettez-moi de
répondre parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup
j'ai entendu beaucoup de contrevérité
ces derniers jours encore il y a
quelques instants dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est je trouve
pas sérieux voilà je le dis comme je le
pense pas pour vous mais pour ceux qui
se sont exprimés je je ne reviendrai pas
donc la vérité c'est que le texte de loi
que nous av n vous proposons d'adopter
un les mesures de de de contraction des
recours c'est la mesure de Monsieur
buffet c'est le rapport sénatorial de
Monsieur buffet qui à partir à votre
parti le président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat il faut l'adopter pour
aller plus vite ça veut pas dire que
tout sera parfait c'està dire qu'on ira
plus vite parce que le temps quand vous
serez mis à l'intérieur chacune et
chacun d'entre vous c'est tout le mal
que je vous souhaite mais vous
constaterez que le temps des recours
empêchent d'exécuter des ETF et permet
aux gens de se marier d'avoir des
enfants bref de créer une vie privée et
familiale en France et donc du coup de
ne pas pouvoir éloigner les personnes
donc on doit contracter les recours en
gardant des recours bien évidemment et
on doit permettre d'expulser du
territoire national toute personne qui
trouble l'ordre public après il est tout
à fait vrai qu'il y aura un juge qui
jugera bien sûr que à la fin des fins il
y a un magistrat qui va regarder la
décision du ministère de l'Intérieur et
qui dira bah voilà entre la vie privée
et familiale et la la violence
intrafamiliale qu'est-ce qui mérite
d'être resté mais moi je vous rappelle
que dans l'affaire iicen mesdames
Messieurs les
parlementaires dans l'affaire
iicen parce que vous avez voté la loi
séparatisme enfin quand je dis vous non
parce que le RN a refusé de la voter
parce que le RN donne des leçons toute
la journée ils n'ont voté ni la loi
séparatisme qui ont permis de de virer
monsieurcissen ni la loi renseignement
donc attaquer des services de
renseignement de façon indu comme l'a
fait le Front National et monsieur
bardellaa qui manifestement ne connaît
rien aux questions du ministère de
l'Intérieur ne même pas voter la loi
renseignement quand on vous la propos il
y a 3 ans objectivement c'est l'hôpital
qui se fiche de la charité et s'il a pas
eu des drames humains objectivement on
pourrait même en rire mais vu que Madame
Le Pen se fait la publicité sur les
drames qui arrivent dans notre pays
éidimment ça nous rend bien possiblement
énervé d'attaquer les agents de la
police nationale qui font un travail
donc vous refusez de leur donner les
moyens parce que vous êtes dans votre
paranoïa des services de renseignement
mais c'est un autre sujet on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans quelques
instants si vous si vous le souhaitez
mais ce qui est tout à fait certain
c'est que dans l'affairecissen par
exemple nous nous avons poussé jusqu'au
bout la logique d'aller au contentieux
on a perdu au Trib adistratif nous avons
gagné au Conseil d'État et monsieurisen
malgré la vie privée familiale malgré
que ces quatre enfants étaient nés en
France malgré le fait qu'il était
propriétaire en France malgré le fait
qu'il était depuis 40 ans en France on a
réussi à l'expulser du territoire
national donc oui il y aura toujours un
juge pour regarder ce que faitis
intérieur et ça s'appelle la démocratie
non ce n'est pas vrai que la loi
immigration n'aurait pas permis de
changer les choses elle aurait permis de
le faire c'est une après une question
d'exécution c'est tout à fait vrai et
donc moi j'essaie de ne pas être défin
en tout cas aujourd'hui je ne peux pas
expulser 4000 délinquants par an en flux
parce queelles sont parce qu'ils sont
protégés par des réserves d'ordre publi
et moi j'invite les républicains je vous
dis monsieur Bouard vous êtes un homme
de bien et comme beaucoup ici j'invite
les républicains mais je je je vous
connais trop pour le savoir et comme
beaucoup de parlementaires y compris je
remercie Monsieur Vico de son expression
républicaine à travaillé sur un texte
très important qui nous permettra d'être
plus efficace et si dans un an la même
situation se reproduit parce que M n'a
pas utilisé les armes du Parlement vous
aurez le droit de dire que mise
intérieur n'a pas exécuté le pouvoir du
Parlement mais c'est étonnant que des
parlementaires ne veuillent pas modifier
la loi s prétexte qu'un jour un juge
donnera tort à une action préfectorale
je voulais vous le dire parce que dans
l'affaire terrible d'aras s'il y a bien
un procès à faire c'est pas celui du
gouvernement du président de la
République merci il me reste 10 orateurs
sur cette discussion alors on reprend
madame SAR tanzili c'est 2 minutes cette
fois-ci hein merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre conforme
aux disposition de la loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur vous avez acté par décret le
30 août dernier la création de l'Office
mineur dédié à la lutte contre les
violences sur les mineurs et rattaché à
la Direction générale de la police
nationale c'était une nécessité au
regard de la hausse des atteintes faites
au mineurs qu'il s'agisse des cas de
harcèlement qui se multiplient avec des
conséquences trop souvent tragiques des
cas de violence physique ou des cas de
violence sexuelle je pense notamment à
l'explosion de la pédocriminalité sur
internet mais aussi à la prise de
conscience autour de l'ampleur de
l'inceste aussi pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous indiquer quelles seront
les priorités de cet office et s'il
bénéficie déjà quelques semaines après
sa création de tous les moyens
nécessaires à son bon fonctionnement je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur Jordan
Guiton merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a une
évolution générale pour les crédits
budgétaires de la mission sécurité pour
ce projet loi de finance suite à la loi
d'orientation et tout au long du texte
lopmi nous avons voté tout ce qui permet
d'augmenter les moyens pour la sécurité
notamment l'augmentation des effectifs
qui permettent de revenir finalement sur
les suppressions des 10000 postes sous
Sarkozi en 2008 les crédits sont à peu
près corrects mais la volonté politique
est absente et notre système pénal est
toujours laxiste depuis vous êtes dans
un immobilisme consternant le cimetière
du terrorisme islamiste en France ne
cesse de s'agrandir les voies navigables
que vous entretenez entre l'Afrique et
la France ne cessent de s'étendre et
l'insécurité ne cesse de gangrainer
notre pays jusque dans la ruralité je
pense à l'explosion des cambralages dans
mon département de l'Aube
qu'attendez-vous pour dissoudre toutes
les organisations islamistes pour fermer
définitivement toutes les mosquées
salafistes et pour expulser tous les
étrangers islamistes alors Monsieur le
Ministre allez-vous continuer de parler
comme Marine Le Pen et d'agir comme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou allez-vous enfin
démissionner de votre fonction comme
vous auriez déjà dû le faire après le
fiasco du Stade de France en accusant à
Tor les supporters anglais après la
fuite de l'imam iqen après la fuite des
migrants de l'océan viking après vos
mensonges récents sur les migrants de
Lampedusa retrouvés dans Paris après
votre mauvais bilan dans les chiffres de
votre ministère on y reviendra tout à
l'heure vous accable et j'ai ajouté j'ai
pas pu m'empêcher la référence après le
débat en 2022 face à Jordane bardellaa
qui vous a mis devant vos
responsabilités devant tous les Français
selon François Hollande selon François
Hollande l'assaillant d'aras aurait pu
être expulsé et par votre démonstration
enrichissante monsieur le ministre on
comprend que ni LR en 2007 ni le PS en
2012 ni vous depuis 2017 vous n'aviez
réussi à l'expulser combien de personnes
radicalisées sont dans ce cas et sont
des bombes humaines comme l Marine Le
Pen qui pourront agir demain contre les
Français ce fait politique ce fait
malheureux résume la vie politique
depuis 15 ans les trois partis au
gouvernement ont échoué une seule
question pourquoi toujours réagir après
les drames et non avant c'est problème
d'écrire son intervention avant d'avoir
écouté la
réponseors simplement monsieur avant de
donner la parole à Monsieur monstardine
la fermeture des lieux de culte dans
lesquels se déroulent les activités
séparatistes c'est la loi séparatiste
d'ailleurs la police des cul qu'on a
fait adopter non maisame le attendez
juste simplement ce que je veis vous
dire c'est que dispositions que vous
appelez de vos vœux elles existent dans
la loi depuis 2021 a voté contre
Monsieur monsardine Merci monsieur le
Président peut-être avant de m'adresser
à monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président je réitère ici cont tenu de la
situation de Mayotte notamment dans le
domaine de l'insécurité ma demande de
voir une mission d'information de notre
de notre commission à maotte cela étant
dit dit monsieur le ministre au qu vous
le sauriez pas je suis de Sada à Mayotte
j'étais maire j'y habite avec toute ma
famille hier nous avons vécu une nuit
difficile avanthier cé dembéi avant
avantiier c'était mamouzu avant avanier
c'était kungou bref vous nous aviez
donné beaucoup d'espoir avec l'opération
mouchou et je voulais le saluer
malheureusement cette opération n'a pas
pu aller jusqu'au bout pour plusieurs
raisonsant d'abord à la discorde au sein
du gouvernement qui n'a pas souhaité
vous soutenir je le dis très franchement
je sais qu'il vous sera difficile de
reconnaître mais la réalité celle-là je
souhaite que euh que vous puissiez
devant la représentation nationale nous
nous dire qu'effectivement vous allez à
nouveau peut-être avant les événements
de du mois de juin prochain renvoyer
remettre en p comme vous l'aviez promis
l'opération ouchou pour essayer de
compléter ce qui a été fait nous vivons
difficilement les Maoris n'en peuvent
plus les mauris sont obligés de fuir
leur territoire et les laissé au gang
alors que lorsque vous avez fait
l'opération bouchou au moins un pan de
ces opérations a pu être fait notamment
euh
d'interpeller les les têtes des les
têtes des gangs il reste à nettoyer les
bidonville ainsi de suite donc dites
mooi la la ce que je souhaite c'est que
vous puissiez nous dire très clairement
et très simplement désormais quelle est
la suite parce que vous êtes resté au
milieu du gay je ne souhaite pas que
vous restiez là je vous demande d'aller
de poursuivre parce que vous avez créé
beaucoup d'espoir à la à lorsque vous
avez engagé cette opération cet espoir
aujourd'hui interroge alors que vous
avez réussi et vous étiez l'un des rares
gouvernementss monsieur monsieur le
Président je fini l'un des membres du
gouvernement qui avait conquis euh la
sympathie de Moré parce qu'ils ont cru
dans votre action madame cl
chassagol merci Monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais
commencer par vous dire qu'il y a SEP
synagogues dans ma circonscription
depuis les attaques barbares du Hamas
nous sommes parcouru par l'effroid et
comme dans tout le pays vous le savez
nos concitoyens de confession juives
sont inquiets des risques pour leur
sécurité face à l'augmentation des actes
antisémites que vous avez vous-même
constaté dans les chiffres du ministère
de l'Intérieur l'antisémitisme serait en
augmentation dans notre société cette
phrase me fait peur en tant qu'élu de la
nation elle me fait peur en tant que
citoyenne en tant qu'historique
cette peur je la partage avec nos
concitoyens de confession juives savoir
que cette inquiétude que cette peur
existe à nouveau qu'elle persiste encore
est insupportable dans une démocratie
qui a pour devise Liberté Égalité
Fraternité la République doit garantir à
chacun la protection la liberté celle de
circuler comme celle d'exercer son culte
alors face à cette inquiétude le
président de la République et vous-même
vous avez rappelé que la République
serait intraitable et garante de la
protection de ses libertés aussi
Monsieur le Ministre comment
comptez-vous rassurer nos compatriotes
et assurer leur protection pourriez-vous
nous préciser les moyens et les
dispositifs que vous mettez en œuvre
pour que nos concitoyens de confession
juives puissent se rendre à la synagogue
sans crainte et amener leurs enfants à
l'école sans peur je vous
remercie monsieur Timothé housoussin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la hausse capacitaire et
budgétaire du ministère de l'Intérieur
correspond à un réel besoin et les
députés RN ont pris leurs responsabilité
en votant la hausse des moyens et
effectifs dédiés à la sécurité à
l'occasion de la lopmi je souhaiterais
cependant vous alerter sur l'effectivité
de ces Hauses par le biais d'un exemple
concret à Vernon dans ma circonscription
une ville durement marquée par les
émeutes de cet été le renfort de H
policiers avait été annoncé par la
préfecture de l'UR en mai dernier non
seulement ces renforts ne sont jamais
arrivés mais aujourd'hui aucune
confirmation de renfort à moyen ou long
terme n'a été faite au commissariat par
la Direction Centrale la police
nationale de Vernon fonctionne à flux
tendu et se trouve dans un véritable
flou quant à l'évolution de de ses
capacités opérationnelles d'autant que
le Commissariat a subi dernièrement des
départs non
compensés une autre problématique de ce
commissariat qui nous concerne
directement puisque nous votons
aujourd'hui les budgets 2024 pour la
sécurité c'est celui des primes à Vernon
comm unee frontalière de l'île-de-fance
les policiers ne bénéficient pas de
prime de fidélisation en secteur
difficile alors que Vernon compte deux
zones de sécurité prioritaires un
policier du commissariat des Mureaux à
30 minutes de route touchera l'indemnité
de fidélisation et une prime de 150 €
par mois soit un salaire
significativement plus élevé qu'av
Vernon ce qui pose un problème
d'attractivité monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que les
hausses d'effectif voté ne sont pas des
effets d'annonce parvenez-vous à tenir
les engagements pris en mai dernier la
police a lancé une campagne pour
recruter 7000 policiers le métier a-t-il
tire aujourd'hui suffisamment de
candidats au-delà des effectifs que
pensez-vous d'une nécessaire évolution
de la rémunération des policiers
prévoyez-vous de revoir la cartographie
des zones bénéficiant de la prime de
fidélisation pour attirer des effectifs
dans certains commissariats moins dotés
comme Vernon ou monargie et enfin je ne
vous demande pas forcément de réponse
immédiate pour ce cas précis mais
pouvez-vous avec l'aide de vos services
nous informer de l'arrivée prévue ou non
de renfort significatif pour le
commissariat de Vernant Monsieur
Philippe guuselin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez beaucoup parl de de recrutement et
à juste titre la loi justice qu'on a
voté la semaine dernière prévoit aussi
des recrutements dans le domaine
pénitentiaires des surveillants or il y
a un vrai sujet d'attractivité pour la
gendarmerie pour les forces de police
pour les gardiens de de de prison donc
vous entendre sur ce sur ce sujet même
si vous avez commencé à à à à répondre
comment mobiliser davantage les les
talents et les garder c'est pas simple
et puis un point sécurité civile en
saluant le le le rapport de notre
collègue Éric pouger euh tout en
n'oubliant pas Thomas rodigose sur la
partie police scientifique et je le
remercie de de nous avoir citer mais un
sujet de financement vous savez que les
pompiers sont souvent à la recherche de
financement au aujourd'hui on a en
réalité un nombre très majoritaire
d'interventions qui sont des secours à
personnes parce que les services
médicaux ne sont pas là hospitaliers ne
peuvent pas répondre à la demande et les
10 les services d'incendier de secours
se trouvent avec des tâches qu'on peut
qualifier d'une certaine façon d'indu
alors bien évidemment les pompiers font
leur boulot et on est tous derrière eux
je tiens à le à le redire mais quelques
question de financement or nous avons
voté il y a peu c'était avant les
grandes vacances un principe exonération
de la titicpe pour les 10 nous avons
aussi écarté le malus écologique et il
se trouve que dans l'article 12 de la
loi de financeces première partie alinéa
80 et 81 cela revient par la petite
porte alors c'est un peu un déni de
démocratie on a l'impression alors que
l'encre est à peine sèche que le
gouvernement reprend reprend pardon ce
qu'on a essayé lui arracher le terme
n'est pas impropre lui arracher d'une
main donc pourriez-vous clarifier votre
situation et la situation des 10 et de
leur financement dans ce cadre je vous
remercie Sansier ce ce qui va vous
répondre le ministre je pense que nous
avons obtenu la restitution des crédits
que nous avions voté dans la loi de
notre collègue pojet monsieur Julien
Rancoule
pardon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il est de notoriété
publique que les associations agréées de
sécurité civile jou un rôle essentiel
pour la sécurité publique en intervenant
dans diverses situations d'urgence de
catastrophees naturell aux accidents
majeurs en passant par les Dispositifs
Prévisionnels de secours elle forme
aussi nos concitoyens au gestes de
premier secours sur ce point le projet
de loi de finan renouvelle l'objectif de
généraliser la formation au gestes de
premier secours en atteignant l'objectif
de 80 % de la population formée au PSC1
ou au gestes qui sauvent d'ici la fin de
la mandature présidentielle cependant
dans le projet de loi de finance 2024
nous constatons que la la direction
générale de la sécurité civile et de la
gestion de crise a une enveloppe de 250
50000 € seulement pour subventionner les
associations concourrant à des missions
de sécurité civile cela paraît
particulièrement faible nous devons être
plus ambitieux pour n nos soutiens pour
notre soutien à ces associations qui
font un travail remarquable avec des
moyens parfois très limités c'est ce
qu'elles nous disent d'ailleurs sur le
terrain quand nous les rencontrons ma
question est donc la suivante
seriez-vous prêt à revoir à la hausse
cette enveloppe consacrée aux
associations concourant à des missions
de sécurité civile encore une fois les
aider c'est dévelop une culture du
risque au sein de la population et à
terme participer à sauver des vies
humaines je vous
remercie
monsieurors madame
Andre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre dans dans
votre budget je crois que il est
prévu comme d'habitude de construire de
nouveaux centres de rétention
administrative oui c'est la loi donc moi
je voulais attirer votre attention sur
comme l'a dit ma ma collègue sur la
formation
des personnel enfin de la police des air
et des frontières puisque je je je tiens
à pororter à votre connaissance que nous
avons vécu ce ce weekend puisque nous
avons fait valoir notre droit de
parlementaire de visiter un centre de
rétention
administrative celui de Lyon
saexupéri et nous avons donc attendu
près de 4 He qu'on va bien nous faire
entrer parce que nous étions accompagnés
de journalistes et que euh c'est le
droit he c'est c'est un droit de pouvoir
en tant que parlementaire faire la
visite d'un centre rétention
administrative accompagné de
journalistes donc nous avons dû
euh subir un incessant aller-retour
entre un interlocuteur et sa direction
que nous n'avons vu que au bout de 4h
donc je repose la question sur la la
formation comment se peut-il que la
police des aires et des frontières ne
soit pas formée à tous les articles du
du czda et donc ce celui-là qui est donc
le le
744-39 et suivant qui euh permett au
parlementaire de visiter un centre de
rétention administrative accompagné de
journalistes
euh c'est très étonnant et je dois vous
le dire parce que de toute façon nous
euh nous ferons
nous vous apporterons un écrit nous
avons été quand même
choqués par la manière avec laquelle
nous avons été reçus nous avons attendu
4h dans un réduit sans fenêtre et nous
étions 7 et nous n'avions pas chacun un
siège pour nous
asseoir monsieur Stéphane
rambau merci monsieur le Président les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques seront
en 2024 un événement mondial de première
importance notre pays sera à cette
occasion en tant que pays organisateur
en première ligne et devra faire face à
des enjeux sécuritaires majeurs monsieur
le ministre le projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 porte pour les crédits
consacrés à la mission sécurité une
véritable ambition à la hauteur des
enjeux qui sont à venir pour autant
d'après un rapport publié le 20 juillet
dernier la Cour des comptes confirme les
inquiétudes déjà soulignées face au
manque d'encadrement en matière de
sécurité du fait de la pénurie
prévisible d'agents de sécurité privé
qui risque d'obliger les forces de
l'ordre national à encore plus de
présence en effet comme vous devez le
savoir aussi bien que moi le secteur
professionnel des agents de sécurité
privée connaît d'importantes difficultés
de recrutement depuis le covid avec des
effectifs
en constante diminution de ce fait le
risque de ne jamais atteindre le nombre
d'agents de sécurité nécessaire à
l'cadrement des cérémonies d'ouverture
et de clôture des jeux ou des épreuves
sportives est évident et obligera
mécaniquement les forces de l'ordre
police et gendarmerie à plus de
disponibilité alors que les tensions
internationales sont extrêmes du fait de
la guerre en Ukraine et en Israël et du
fait terroriste il est évident que cette
question de la sécurité des jeux ne
serurait être minimisé ma question est
donc simple monsieur le ministre vous
qui vous plaignez il y a quelques
minutes de ne pas voir de questions du
rassemblement national pensez-vous que
les sommes que vous avez prévu de
mobiliser pour assurer les faits
inhérents à la prise en charge de la
sécurité pour les Jeux Olympiques
seront-ils suffisants ou disposez-vous
d'une certaine marge de manœuvre pour
les adapter aux nécessités qui pourrait
se faire jour
Monsieur Merci
merci monsieur le Président deux deux
types de questions un peu différentes si
vous me permettez Monsieur le Ministre
d'abord en saluant toujours l'action de
nos forces de l'ordre et nos services de
renseignement dans cette période au
combien difficile et sensible qui
malheureusement pour reprendre la
formule d'un ancien patron de la DGSI
risque à nouveau de nous conduire sur un
long chemin tragique
euh un mot pour vous demander où nous en
sommes des laissés passer consulairirees
attribué par la algérie le Maroc la
Tunisie je sais pas si vous y avez
répondu si ça m'aurait échappé tout à
l'heure mais une question simple
deuxièmement je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur la gravité de la
recrudesence du trafic de drogue dans
notre pays aujourd'hui la drogue
gangrain tout outre les vies qu'elle met
en cause elle est au cœur de tous les
réseaux de criminalité de criminalité
organisée on a vu les menaces que la
criminalité organisée sous forme de
trafic de stupéfiants faisait peser sur
des démocraties comme les Pays-Bas et la
Belgique on en est peut-être pas là mais
on voit la multiplication du trafic les
chiffres sont effarants 250000 mis en
cause dans le cadre d'affaires de trafic
de stupéfiant ou de consommation 3
milillard2 millions de chiffres
d'affaires on n'est pas loin de 50
assassinats sur fond de trafic de drogue
à
Marseille aujourd'hui c'est une alerte
rouge que nous sonnons monsieur le
ministre vous annoncez souvent des
chiffres et c'est c'est légitime dans
vos fonctions où
vous former une forme d'autosatisfaction
permanente on l' vu sur d'autres sujets
mais les chiffres que vous annoncez
traduisent je crois une explosion du
trafic de consom de la consommation
également quelle mesures très concrètes
vous comptez prendre pour enrayer ce
trafic qui gangrainene des territoires
qui sont aujourd'hui aux mains des
trafiquants et non plus aux mains des
autorités de la République
merci pour pour bonne information
monsieur ministre mais aussi monsieur
lequest on a une mission d'information
sur ces sujets sur l'évaluation de la
politique de lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiant en France qui é au rapport de
notre collègue claragol et de notre
autre collègue Antoine léom il reste
monsieur gilet ensuite vous pourrez
répondre monsieur
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le
ministre vous prévoyez en 2024 pour le
fond interministériel de prévention de
la délinquence une baisse record de près
de 26 % des crédits qui seront alloués à
ce fond alors il faut rappeler ce qui ce
fond le FIPD ce fond il permet de
financer la
vidéosurveillance la sécurisation des
établissements scolaires l'équipement
des polices municipales la protection
des sites sensibles culturels par
exemple la prévention de la
radicalisation et de la lutte contre le
séparatisme alors comme si tout allait
bien en France comme si nous n'étions
pas sous une menace terroriste islamiste
forte comme si l'insécurité n'était pas
galopante et bien vous baissez ce fond
qui est très attendu dans nos
territoires dont nos élus locaux ont
fortement besoin on croit rêver alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question elle
est Simp qu allez-vous arrêter de parler
comme un Le Pen pour agir comme un
Mélenchon
merci au moins les éléments langage sont
maîtrisés monsieur le ministre allez-y
oui en fait je essayer de lire comme
comme quelqu'un de normal monsieur le
député et je vous encourage à faire
peut-être pareil et peut-être de répéter
la chose que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
que j'ai déjà répondu à la question mais
il n pas plus sour que celui qui ne veut
pas entendre 80 millions d'euros en
2022 84 millions d'euros en 2023 ça
c'est cette année 87 millions d'euros
2024 donc en fait 87 c'est plus que 84
et c'est plus que 80 et c'est 94 en 2025
et sur le sous plafond du FIPD qui sont
les caméras vidéo protection 22 millions
d'euros 2023 25 millions 2024 et je vous
ferai dire monsieur le député qu'on a
rajouté d'ailleurs 20 millions poste
émeut ou 2 million et demi seulement
sont consommés je n'ai d'ailleurs pas eu
demande de ville du rassemblement
national sur ces crédits euh c'est tout
à fait vrai c'est tout à fait vrai un
crédit exceptionnel j'ai pas eu de
demande donc et par contre ce qui est
vrai c'est que j'ai écrit V du
rassemblement national pour demander
quand est-ce qu'ils accueiller un CRRA à
part le maire de fraisjus qui m'a
répondu NON au moins honnêtement aucune
ville du rassemblement national ne m'a
monsieur non non mais monsieur monsieur
le député ne vous fâchez pas quand vous
prend la main le pot la main dans le pot
de confiture vous réclamez des centres
de rétention mais ailleurs voilà donc
j'ai écris à tous les Maes du
rassemblement national aucun ne m'a
proposé un terrain heureusement qu'il y
a d'autres ma courageux qu' l'ont fait
qui n'appartient pas à votre camp à
votre camp politique ce qui permet d'
leur dire non mais le maire de Nice est
courageux vous avez raison de dire
monsieurti vous avez raison de souigner
le courage du ma de Nice on s'attendait
pas avec Monsieur Pradal un tel soutien
comme ça spontané et Monsieur et
Monsieur Commission des LO je don la
parole pour défendre monsieur après
peut-être mais mais vraiment merci
Monsieur de cette honnêteté qui j'en
suis rejaillli dans la viille municipale
niissoise
euh la question qui qui se pose aussi
c'est c'est finalement j'ai fait un
petit calcul quand même parce que je
savais que comme ça pas été dit dans
l'émic tout à l'heure j'étais un peu
frustré on a regardé combien de fois
vous avez demandé la démission de
membbrre du gouvernement parce que c'est
quand même une politique assez sympa du
rassembl national il y a eu SEP demandes
de démission de Christophe Castaner bon
il y a eu alors c'est plus rigolo c'est
plus rigolo C cinq demandes de démission
de de Julien de Normandie plus
étonnamment mais il y a eu également neu
demandes de démission du président de la
République notamment Madame Le Pen et
Monsieur Bardella pant le cadre des des
retraites non c'est il y a eu quatre
demandes de démission madame borne voilà
moi je je suis je suis assez déçu parce
que je ah oui il y a eu SEP demandes de
démission des règ du PTI et et alors moi
j'en ai eu que deux jusqu'à présent donc
je un peu frustré je me suis demandé
d'ailleurs si ce matin vous avez pas
demandé ma démission demander ma
démission suite àattentat de Bruxelles
bref ce n'est pas très sérieux ce serait
bien peut-être que nous des propositions
du rassemblement national comme l'a très
bien dit le président de la commission
des lois vous n'avez pas voté la loi C
tisme Madame Le Pen ni madame Marion
maréchal Le Pen ne l'ont voté aucune des
deux elles ont même voté contre la loi
séparatisme comme elles ont voté contre
la loi renseignement vous n'avez pas
donné vous n'avez pas donné les moyens
au ministère de l'Intérieur de faire ce
que vous demandez de faire en fait vous
vivez des problèmes la vérité c'est que
quand on veut résoudre des problèmes
vous ne voulez pas nous aider à le faire
mais continuez ainsi je pense qu'on aura
des discussions très intéressantes
pendant la loi
immigration bien
euh nous avons donc la question de
Monsieur Mansour Camard ah oui la
question pardon pour faire le
rassemblement national jusqu'au bout
pour Vernon je vous propose de corriger
vos chiffres monsieur le député 2020 il
y a effectivement 42 gardiens de la paix
2023 59 gardiens de la paix au moment où
je parle on ira les voir ensemble on les
doit à Sébastien le Cornu parce que vous
m'avez d'ailleurs jamais écrit pour
votre propre commissariat et vous me
remercierez pas pour les trois brigades
de gendarme Marie nouvelle dans l'heure
qu'il aideent sans doute également les
gens de l'heur à mieux vivre il y a
desations d'effectifs également à Val-de
Reuil et dans la circonscription
d'hévreux donc c'est c'est déjà assez
compliqué comme ça pour les policiers
c'est pas la peine de mentir sur les sur
les effectifs en tout cas donner des
chiffres qui sont absolument faux donc
oui ces effectifs sont bien là en
faut-il plus c'est une discussion
intéressante mais c'est pas la peine
d'expliquer qu'ils ont baissé lorsqu'ils
ont augmenté sinon effectivement on en
perd c'est
petit ne ne ne mettez pas en cause la
parole des fonctionnaires de la
République c'est un peu un peu voilà
voilà mais n'hésitez pas en parler au
ministre Lecu qui s'occupe bien de de sa
ville pour monsieur pour monsieur
camardine vous avez parfaitement raison
sur l'opération vanouchou elle a été en
partie une réussite des difficultés
incontestables bien sûr mais en parti
une réussite notamment sur l'ordre
public vous l'avez d'ailleurs vous-même
souligné puisque sur les 50 objectifs de
la police judiciaire
49 ont été interpell et d'ailleurs une
très grande partie d'entre eux sont sous
main de justice et pour d'autres
désormais en prison c'est une très bonne
chose et oui nous allons continuer
monsieur le député alors il y a eu des
événements effectivement à Sada je v
dire que je ne peux pas trop en parler
parler mais je peux comme je vous l'ai
dit en dehors de de ce micro nous
prenons ça les choses nous prenons les
choses extrêmement au sérieux et je peux
vous redire qu'il n aura évidemment une
réponse extrêmement ferme aux événements
qui se sont déroulés où les gendarmes
ont été par ailleurs extrêmement
courageux vous l'avez vous-même souigné
il y a cinq escadron de gendarmerie
mobile désormais à Mayotte donc de plus
qu'avant l'opération vanouchou et puis
nous allons continuer bien évidemment
avec une opération vanouchou 2 on aura
l'occasion d'en d'en reparler il y a
plus de 1000 bangas qui sont détruits ce
qui n'a jamais été atteint vous le savez
bien euh à Mayotte et euh nous avons
avec nos amis euh Maoré à travailler
contre l' immigration irrégulière euh
tout à fait tout à fait d'accord la loi
immigration permettra sans doute d'être
encore plus efficace euh on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler je peux vous
assurer monsieur le député que euh notre
volonté est extrêmement forte euh d'être
ferme contre l'immigration irrégulière
et contre la délinquence à à Mayotte
comme je l'ai déjà comme je l'ai déjà
prouvé alors la question qui se pose euh
de Monsieur Gosselin sur la TICPE
apporte une réponse qu'effectivement a
fait monsieur le président de la
commission des lois Bercy nous a répondu
que c'était malencontreusement que euh
le renouveau de cette taxe euh existait
pour les 10 euh le ministre des comptes
publices vous l'avez vu s'est exprimé
publiquement pour dire qu'il
supprimerait effectivement ce que les
parlementaires avaient supprimé dont
acte tant mieux euh je pense que vous
avez votre réponse monsieur le député
nous partageons votre volonté
effectivement de voir que le respect du
du vote des parlementaires soit soit
soit tenu par le gouvernement euh sur
les secours à la personne alors vous
avez parfaitement raison on a parlé tout
à l'heure avec les les carences
ambulancière il y a un sujet sur lequel
ce serait à mon avis intéressant de
discuter monsieur le député goselin
c'est que souvent ceux qui s'occupent du
secours à la personne qui est désormais
80 à 90 % des interventions des 10 c'est
qui est pas le métier premier des
pompiers surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de
secour à la personne qui pourrait être
fait par d'autres personnes
bon ce sont les départements et qui
s'occupe du
grandâge ce sont les départements et il
y a un travail à faire suroute avec
département pour connecter les
politiques publiques de d'unême
département et vous avez été conseil
départemental je l'ai été également
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'interventions
dans les les pompiers de ma
circonscription ou tous les pompiers que
je rencontre dans mes déplacements
disent quoi quand c'est du secours à la
personne parce queil y a pas le médecin
ou il y a pas l'ambulance il y a pas le
SAMU le le pompier le fait bien
volontiers même si évidemment c'est
parfois difficile parce que c'est pas le
cœur de son métier mais quand il
intervient parce que la télécommande est
tombée de la damag là où on a fait du
maintien à domicile ou pire dans des
épades où il y a il a plus de gardien de
la nuit et on appelle les pompiers pour
pouvoir intervenir là le pompier
évidemment se sent frustré et donc il a
sans doute un travail plus intelligent à
faire collectivement pour que les
pompiers puissent limiter leur secours à
la personne au cas les plus graves par
des enjeux techniques par des enjeux
aussi de relais d'autres personnels qui
pourrai le faire bien volontiers en tout
cas moi je vais y travailler avec les
les 10 parce que je pense que c'est une
manière assez concrète d'abord de rendre
le service public et puis de limiter les
les dépenses des départements des dis et
et de l'État comme je dit l'état
contribue quand même à un/art 1 milliard
d'euros sur 4 milliards au
fonctionnement des 10 ce qui n'est pas
sa
vocation principale euh sur la question
qui a été posée euh sur le financement
je pense qu'on y a répondu en partie
tout à l'heure et ce sera l'occasion
sans doute la partie 2 du du du PLF il y
a sans doute une différence assez forte
entre départements monsieur le monsieur
le député c'est sûr que dans votre
département les besoins sont importants
la population est plutôt pauvre on a des
difficultés a avec le réchauffement
climatique en même temps que des
difficultés avec le secours à la
personne alors que vous avez une taxe
qui est moins dynamique et des recettes
qui sont moins dynamiques dans un
département qui a des recettes foncières
moins dynamiques surtout au moment de
l'immobilier d'aujourd'hui et puis il y
a des départements plus riches notamment
les départements où il y a pas de feu de
forêt péri urbain franilien qui eux ont
plus de recettes alors qu'ils ont euh
des is cert importants mais qui ne sont
pas euh euh en difficultés financière
donc il y a sans doute à à avoir un aide
de l'État une aide financière au sens de
la fiscalité à réfléchir est-ce que la
TSA encore une fois c'est le bon impôt
est-ce qu'il est bien versé il est versé
au département qu' reverse au 10 il y a
parfois tout le monde ne verse pas la
même chose il y a parfois des codes par
qui sont pris on peut toujours en
discuter puis il y a des solidarités
entre départements parce que quand on
voit comment équiper et l'État il
contribue quand il fait le PACT
capacitaire des départements comme le
Méloir le finister le Jura qui doivent
désormais s'équiper en moyen feu de
forêt bah voilà c'est des équipements
extrêmement lourds très chers à payer
des informations très fortes par sa pas
pompier PE peut-être qu'on pourrait
penser que les départements les plus
riches les 10 les plus riches pourraient
y contribuer là je vois que l'ancien
président des appes Maritimes n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord mais je je je je ne
voudrais pas convoquer la richesse qui
n'est pas si évidente que ça parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de difficultés au maritimes
de pauvreté mais aussi de feu de forêt
de calamité de calamité et où l'État
vous accompagne beaucoup monsieur le
Président voilà vous avez oublié de le
mentionner dans votre intervention donc
je voulais ici vous le vous le dire vous
direz du bien donc de l'État et de Ch
dans la même intervention faites
attention donc évidemment on est tout à
fait prêt monsieur le député gostin
puisqu'on a commandé des des rapports à
à pouvoir corriger corriger cela sur les
les laisser passer consulair monsieur
monsieur siti je peux pas répondre à
votre question parce Queen fait les
crédits imigration c'est la semaine
prochaine donc j'avais j'avais imaginé
des crédits je pensais que on
s'intéresserait au crédit de la sécurité
et merci de saluer les forces de police
et l'administration territorale la
sécurité routière ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la reprise des laisser
passer consulaire euh alors avec les
pays d'Afrique est très bonne avec les
pays du Maghreb est meilleur notamment
depuis plusieurs semaines et je voudais
saluer ici le travail que nous faisons
avec l'Algérie et le Maroc dans des
conditions qui font honneur à à l'action
diplomatique du président de la
République plus compliqué avec d'autres
pays notamment la Tunisie désormais
puisque sans doute du fait des des
difficultés que nous traversons toutes
et tous dans la Méditerranée mais la
reprise des laisser passer consulair ce
se confirme elle n'est pas un niveau à
100 % ce serait mentir que de vous le
dire mais elle rejoint les niveaux de
2019 qui est la meilleure année de tous
les laissés passer consire que connu le
ministère de l'intérieur on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir je vous promets
pour la semaine prochaine de faire un
point sur ce sujet je vourais d'ailleurs
dire à Monsieur soti que Monsieur buffet
et la majorité sénatoriale a rajouté
dans le Tex immigration une disposition
que nous n'avions pas prévu de
conditionnement des visas par rapport à
les passés consula et que chaque année
minintérieur et minist Affaires
étrangères de façon justifié moi je
vraai un avis favorable euh à la
l'amendement quand il reviendra au Sénat
en séance parce que parfaitement raison
pour les chose soit évidemment lié on
sait tous qu'il faut le lier aussi au
niveau européen pour plein de raisons
que vous connaissez mais je pense que
c'est une bonne politique que nous
devons que nous devons mener vous posez
la question de la drogue alors je
pourrais vous répondre Nice évidemment
je pourrais vous dire il y a eu 563
gardes à vue depuis le 1er janvier de
cette année grâce aux policiers nissois
qu'on a eu 11 kg de cocaïne c'est quand
même beaucoup dans une ville tis bien
évidemment et 230000 € d'avoir saisi et
c'est skilo d'erme encore une fois qui a
été opéré voilà encore quelques quelques
semaines et surtout 42 armes et ce que
je voudrais vous dire Monsieur sitis
c'est que je ne suis pas tout à fait
certain mais mais votre mission
d'information le dira que et c'est un
peu le même principe que la fraude
fiscale que lorsqu'on saisit plus c'est
parce qu'il y a plus de drogue je pense
que quand on s plus c'est aussi on peut
aussi le dire qu'on est un peu meilleur
collectivement et notamment la police
cependant ce qui est tout à fait vrai
c'est que le trafic de drogue mute de
trois manières un il y a là où il y
avait auparavant des lieux de
consommation et des lieux de Deal
notamment dans les grandes villes au
abord de quartiers plus difficiles c'est
moins le cas en proportion et c'est plus
le cas dans des communes moyennes ou
dans des petites communes qui ne le
connaissaient pas avant ou très peu donc
il y a une sorte de mutation du trafic
de drogue dans sa géographie on y voit
aussi les coûts qu'onortent mais pas
simplement il y a aussi une nouvelle
clientèle qui qui qui naî et peut-être
le phénomène des nouveaux les nouveaux
ruraux il y il y a plein d'explications
qui qui s'expliquent donc peut-être
qu'il faut que nous améliorons davantage
notre tactique contre la drogue au fur à
mesure du nouveau terrain que nous
constatons toutes et tous
incontestablement des villes moyennes
touchées ou des petites vill touché ce
qui était pas le cas auparavant
deuxièmement monsieur CTI je pense que
ce qu'on peut dire c'est pour ça que je
suis une 42 armes à Nice c'est la
présence de plus en plus d'armes dans le
trafic de drogue désormais j'avais
retenu un chiffre il est peut-être
imprécis parce que je pensais pas être
POS qu' poser cette question mais j'ai
cru comprendre que sur 40 % désormais
des interpellations fait par la police
sur une quelconque affaire de drogue il
y a une arme un couteau un pistolet ou
plus grave et donc ce n'était pas le cas
auparavant puisque j'avais retenu que
c'était seulement 10 % il y a 5 ans donc
les gens s'équipent de plus en plus
d'armes quand ils trafiquent de la
drogue et donc ça ça ça pose des
questions aussi je dirais pas
militarisation mais en tout cas
d'armement et donc de violence ce qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant à qui va
avec le trafic et puis troisièmement on
peut aussi regarder les choses avec
parfois satisfaction nous n'avons pas en
France les drogues que connaissent
beaucoup de pays du monde et qui
touchent fondamentalement la vie par
exemple fantanil aux États-Unis première
cause de mortalité désormais des
Américains ou l' qui touche beaucoup de
pays européens qui ne touche pas je
pense moi j'ai mon explication elle
n'est pas que culturelle je pense que le
travail très important que fait l'état
français que d'autres d'État n'ont plus
fait je pense alors avant le changement
courageux aux Pays-Bas le fait que les
Pays-Bas ont laissé faire pendant
longtemps la Belgique parfois pendant
longtemps l'Espagne pendant longtemps
on crée parfois des empires financiers
qui ont permis non seulement de faire du
trafic de drogue de faire venir de
nouvelles drogues encore plus mortell
encore plus létales et notamment c'est
le cas des drogues de synthèse qui sont
évidemment aussi tout à fait à à à
surveiller parce que il y a des moments
où on essaie de courir après la la
technologie pour les découvrir ces
drogues de synthèse qui sont parfois
difficiles et a un très bon laboratoire
vous le savez de la gendarmerie
nationale à Pontoise d'ailleurs
j'encourage le Parlement monsieur le
Président à venir le visiter dans ce cas
de sa mission d'in formation pour
découvrir les nouvelles drogues parce
qu'il y a des drogues que nous
connaissons sans doute pas et que nous
devons contrôler mais aussi dire à
Monsieur sioti que évidemment nous
évitons ainsi les mafias qui sont
extrêmement puissantes vous avez
parfaitement raison de le rappeler de
mettre en coupe régler des ports comme
c'est le cas d'env ou de Rotterdam
parfois de menacer ou de tuer des
journalistes ou des avocats ou des
hommes politiques donc oui le combat
contre la drogue est très difficile non
je ne suis pas certain que plus on
saisit euh plus ça veut dire qu' a de
trafic je pense que ça peut être aussi
le fait qu' qu'on est aussi efficace et
c'est le rôle des policiers des
gendarmes indépendamment des ministres
d'e qui succèdent mais mais surtout on a
affaire à des drogues qui changent plus
mortelle plus addictive et plus plus
plus malheureusement efficace dans leur
mortalité je
voudrais dire un un petit mot sur le
travail des agents de sécurité privée
puisque j'aiété interrogé par un député
du rassemblement national moi je
constate d'abord que la coupon de rugby
se passe sans aucun problème et compris
pr de sécurité privée ça c'est un point
très important j'ai pas bien compris le
fait vous parliez de budget pour la
sécurité privée pour les J je rappelle
que la sécurité privée pour les jees
Olympiques c'est l'organisateur qui qui
le fait et qui lance des appels d'offre
donc ce pas l'état le CIO n'est pas
l'état voilà en revanche ce qu'a fait
l'état il a fait beaucoup de choses il a
formé 25000 personnes à la sécurité
privée il va encore former beaucoup
d'autres il a permis d'augmenter de 7 %
en forçant les entreprises de sécurité
privée augmenter les salaires puisque
c'est aussi uneentreprise qui payaient
pas extrêmement bien leurs agences c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire pour une
partie d'entre eux et donc évidemment
c'est pas une question simplement de
paiement par l'entreprise c'est aussi
que l'entreprise P bien ses salariés
j'espère que vous leur dites dans les
contacts que vous avez manifestement
avec eux en tout cas l'État était au au
au rendez-vous et puis je pense que ce
qui est très important c'est de voir que
aujourd'hui il nous reste il nous manque
à peu près 8 à 10 % d'agents de sécurité
privé il nous reste 9 mois avant les
Jeux Olympiques euh ça dépend des
endroits ça dépend des lieux ça dépend
comment et a notamment énorme question
de logement où est-ce que nous logeons
les agents de sécurité privé qui
viennent de province qui vient répondre
à des marchés et ça vous savez qu'en
î-de-france dans un contexte très
contraint c'est une là pour le coup une
des réponses que peut apporter l'État
mais moi j'ai grande confiance dans
l'action collective et notamment
l'action du CEO parisque tous ces appels
d'offres ne sont pas encore lancés tous
ces appels d'offres n'ont pas encore
obtenu de de réponses quoi qu'il en soit
la sécurité sera évidemment observée par
le ministère de l'Intérieur bien
évidemment
euh madame la députée m'a interrogé sur
euh ce qu'elle considérait être
manifestement comm une mésaventure
lorsqu'elle a voulu visiter le centre de
rétention administrative de
saint-exupéri j'ai cru voir dans votre
intervention un hommage au travail
difficile des policiers aux frontières
dans les centres de rétention je vous
remercie de de souligner le leur travail
leur travail difficile alors j'ai pas
tout à fait puisque je me suis renseigné
euh et c'est votre droit le plus strict
bien évidemment de visiter les centres
de rétention ratif euh je je je je je
n'ai pas tout à fait les mêmes déroulés
des faits donc je regarderai bien bien
volontiers vous avez dit 4h j'ai compris
que j'ai compris que vous avez entendu
2h20 ce ce qui est déjà beaucoup hein je
je ne le conteste je ne le cont j'ai
tendance à croire les les les policiers
en général donc on va évidemment
demander à Madame la préfette
puisqu'elle avait été elle avait été
saisie puisque je comprends bien ce ce
sujet vous êtes venu avec des
journalistes mais aussi avec des
attachés parlementaires ce qui là n'est
pas prévu dans le code qui prmet aux
parlementaires d'intervenir donc c'est
je pense que la prochaine fois il faut
se conformer au code il faut se
conformer il faut se conformer au code
et c'est les parlementaires qui sont les
représentants de la nation c'est pas
leur attacher parlementaire peut-être
que ça explique une partie de la
difficulté que que vous avez eu que vous
avez s'il vous plaît que vous avez eu
que vous avez eu parce que là je je je
je je vois qu'il y a trois attachés
parlementaires qui vous ont accompagné
ce qui montre que la police aux
frontière n'a rien à cacher et a permis
cette visite deux journalistes en effet
de de Médi part qui vous ont qui vous
ont accompagné et on a dû rappeler me
semble-t-il à à vous-même ENF en tout
cas à ceux qui menaient la la la comment
dirais-je la la visite que il fallait
évidemment respecter l'identité des
personnes soit des personnes qui sont
retenues en CRRA soit des policiers -mêm
ce qui est manifestement pas toujours
été le cas puisque j'ai par exemple le
fait que le chef de centre a été
interrogé tout au long de la visite avec
micro et caméra toujours enclenché bon
donc on va on va on va évidemment faire
un un point rendu puisque j'ai aussi un
retour de la police nationale qui
évoquait je cite hein les thématiques
ciblées et les propos agressif parfois
très insistant à la limite à la limite à
la limite de l'insulte à la limite de
l'insulte donc écoutez si il y a
manifestement il y a manifestement
quelqu'un qui étaé discourtoi j'espère
que ce n'est pas évidemment les les
visiteurs on va évidemment regarder ça
avec Madame la préfette avec la préfette
évidemment avec la préfette de la région
de la région renal pauarne voilà s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît il y a des
policiers madame vous savez qui passent
des heures à travailler sans pouvoir
s'asseoir également donc si vous
découvrez qu'il faut plus de moyens pour
la police nationale n'hésitez pas à
voter des crédits supplémentaires ce
n'est pas le ministère de l'Intérieur ce
n'est pas le ministère de l'Intérieur si
vous plaîtsur ber ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas le ministère de l'Intérieur qui va
refuser des crédits supplémentaires bien
évidemment voilà ce que je voulais dire
en quelques mots je pense que j'ai
répondu à
pardonors ah oui pardon excusez-moi vous
avez parfaitement raison donc sur les
moyens je rappelle que nous avons donné
21 millions d'euros aux associations
l'année dernière pour compenser leur
pertes pendant le covid se rajoute les
250000 en effet pour les moyens de la
sécurité la protection à sécurité CIV
qui font en effet un travail formidable
moi j'ai pas eu de demande
d'augmentation de de crédit de leur part
mais si c'est le cas il y a pas de
problème pour étudier si les mississions
sont supplémentaires ou si ça correspond
pas à leur besoins pour être au
rendez-vous puisqueeffectivement ce que
le travail qu'ils font est
incomparablement efficace et permettre
au service public d'être bien rendu donc
si jamais il m'interroge je le ferai
bien volontiers
ah oui il a ré sur les synagogue
ministre alors sur la protection des
synagogues mais je pensais avoir répondu
tout à l'heure mais je m'en suis désolé
madame la la députée peut-être que je
suis un peu fatigué nousous aujourd'hui
au point où nous en sommes de la menace
terroriste à la suite des attentats
islamistes terroristes inacceptables
contre la population israélienne nous
avons protégé l'intégralité des li cules
qui éta à notre connaissance à parfois
il y a des salles de prière plus
complexes et donc je réinvite à chaque
fois la communauté à à nous faire savoir
un certain nombre de de lieux ça fait
580 sites en tout synagogue mais aussi
lieux communauta culturelle mais aussi
école confessionnelle et alors c'est
plus de 10000 policiers gendarmes pour
tenir ces ces sites dans les entrées
sorties et donc c'est pour ça que nous
avons demandé l'appui de sentinelle hein
il y a eu 4000 militaires en plus rien
que dans la ressort de la préfecture de
police de Paris petite couronne et Paris
c'est 343 sites voilà et donc évidemment
c'est une protection queon doit au
Français de confession juive euh je veux
dire aussi que les moyens euh de caméra
de vidéo protection puisque la loi de
Séparation des Églises et l'État
n'empêche pas de pouvoir sécuriser les
lieux de culte qu' soi juifs musulmans
ou chrétiens et donc le les le culte
juif est le premier bénéficiaire du FIPD
pour plus de 3 millions et demi je suis
en mesure de vous annoncer que les 3,4
ou 3,8 million l'intégralité des 86
projets proposés par la communauté juive
a été accepté par le ministère de à
l'intérieur pour équiper notamment en
vidéosurveillance mais aussi pour être
en en contact avec la sécurité et
notamment la sécurité privée qui garde
les sites en dehors des menaces
terroristes donc un hommage à Christian
Estrosi c'est ça je je suis présid pas
la commission
mais c'est presque un fait personnel
monsieur le ministre vous avez ironisé
vous avez ironisé sur cette question
d'abord je vous remercie d'avoir accepté
l'amendement que j'avais porté portant à
3000 le nombre de places de cras et dans
ce cadre je vous rappelle et j'ai eu des
échanges nourris avec vos cabinets que
j'ai fait une proposition je sais pas si
le maire de Nice en a fait mais pour
créer un cras sur le site de l'aéroport
sur le site de l'ancienne triostale qui
serait à quelques mètres de l'aéroport
et qui permettrait de tripler ou de
quadrupler le nombre de places
totalement insuffisante aujourd'hui à
Nice puisqu'il y a à peine 30 places en
CRRA alors qu'on est le département qui
a la plus grande pression migratoire à
la frontière merci je vous REM monsieur
le ministre un dernier propos et ensuite
on la la séance non mais je dis bien
volontiers que l'augmentation des craqu
on avait N place qu'on avait prévu
n'était pas celle que vous avez fait
adopter donc je je le répète sans cesse
monsieur vous avez raison c'est la
coconstruction du centre comme quoi on
peut se mettre d'accord sur des taxis
compris qui touchent l'immigration hein
voilà le cent centre de rétention de
centre de rétention administratif donc
vous avvez constaté que j'ai annoncé les
11 projets un à maotte et 10 sur le
territoire métropolitain Nice c'est
dedans le lieu exact la localisation
exacte on va vous la donner si on la
donne pas en séance on vous la
donnera la la semaine la semaine
prochaine je vrais d'ailleur remercier
ici publiquement les communes qui ont
accepté que nous mettions des centres de
réttention administrative sur leur
commune ce qui est jamais évident mais
aussi l'administration pénitentiaire
monsieur le Président et monsieur le
garde des saau puisque ce sont souvent
des terrains de la pénitentiare que nous
avons pu récupérer pour construire près
des lieux de détention des centres de
rétention administratif afin que
notamment les policiers pour les sortant
de prison n'ai pas parcourir
l'intégralité d'un département donc on a
en plus essayé d'être intelligent et
faire des cras à taille à taille à peu
près à peu près correct puisque c'est
110 places en moyenne et donc nous
aurons donc 3000 plac de CR pour
2027 nous allons suspendre la séance on
reprendra à 21h30 je va envoyer une
convocation rectificative 21h30 par la
discussion générale de Monsieur Bernal
malheureusement à nouveau l'absence du
ministre